all righty dude we're rolling happy new year
happy new year what is that okay what is that response yeah well yeah i've been dealing with
plumbing issues not stopped for the last oh my gosh are you kidding me what a way to start with a
hot water heater then then a sewer drain line and yeah it's just not so fun you dropped that's right
you dropped that chat in the picture in the chat the other day of literally like your bathtub filled
with sewer water dude my wife she was like hey could you come like look at this really quick and
i was like yeah i just like i thought it was gonna be something simple and then just like that's
absorbed my entire life like hey i don't think it's supposed to look like this you know like
it was like and then i was like huh i was like trying to debug it i like went into the garage
like go check it out turns out the washing machine was running and because the whole line was blocked
the it was like dumping water oh no the garage there's like a half inch of water just like
sitting on the floor oh gosh it was a mess it was a mess dude that's terrible well i i have had not
the best new year either i have had a little cold well you know so we all have our our struggles right
everyone has their own problems they're struggling with joel um no that's hilarious all right man um so
here's what we're what we're given to the people this week um me and joel and some of the wonderful
listeners uh some of the wonderful critical thinkers subscribers to the discord um ctv podcast discord
have put together the best content of 2023 um for you listeners um we have three primary sections we've
divided this up into we have technical content from justin and joel we've got interviews and then
we've got sort of bug stories so we've got about three hours of content that we're gonna sort of
recap and kind of put it in all of this is oriented specifically towards very technical content so it
should be very technically informative um so i'm excited to get into it we'll just kind of give you
guys an intro to each one of them as they come through so joel is that is that all we got to cover
this morning yeah i mean the only thing i'll say is as you mentioned the ctvb discord that's uh we're
doing a lot of really awesome stuff the community's growing lots of really cool research and questions
and tips and tricks and tools and everything being posted in there so if that sounds interesting to
you go ahead and check it out it's ctvb.show slash discord and that'll take you right to the server
invoice the server invite link sweet dude first up on the list is the technical content from justin
and joel's section and the first one is episode 26 client side quirks and browser hacks and in this
segment we're talking about exploiting html injection with meta tags and base tags anywhere in the response
body so hope you enjoy this segment but yeah so the other thing that i kind of want to mention and this
was actually sparked by a bug at a live hacking event which you probably know the one that i'm talking
about um but uh a friend of ours uh used a meta tag to get a really really crazy bug at a live hacking
event um because he had an html injection um and uh and so this is something that i just kind of wanted
to make sure everyone was aware of because whenever you have html injection it's it feels kind of bad
you know if you can't get it to to xss but depending on the context there's still a lot you can do
um and meta and base tags are two of the primary tags that you can use to to really do something
cool with yeah um i mean this cheat sheet is awesome there's a ton of cheat sheets out there but i think
you know uh keep some of your own notes i think is like the the key i would say because like
otherwise you're gonna have a folder that's got 50 different cheat sheets that are bookmarked in it and
when you're trying to think of that one thing you're gonna have to click through all of them
define them um yeah but yeah this is really really interesting i didn't actually um i don't really
fiddle with meta tags very much and i think it's kind of underrated i like early on like way back in
the day like meta tags used to be like a much easier exploit scenario where you could just like
set like base urls or something like that that would allow you to exploit them i don't know how much
that's still possible yeah so some of the functionality because you used to be able to i think trigger
xss via um via a meta tag and right um according to this cheat sheet it's still possible using a data
uri this was not something i got to test before um the episode it says here that it only works in safari
so i can't test it right now joel if you i don't know if you second most popular browser yeah exactly
seriously if you've got your you know i don't know if you're on your mac right now but if you want
to just throw that little um you know data scheme into the in to safari and see if it works then go
for it but um but meta essentially has a bunch of functionality and one of the cool attributes of it
is this http equiv attribute and originally it was designed to allow you to essentially set http headers
inside of the the page like sort of i guess sort of retroactively because it's like you've already
loaded the body of the request um and i feel like there's a lot more potential for that um you know
than then is possible right now but um if you if you look at this you know see if i can pull up this
picture that i had in the in the doc the current values that are accessible for that are content security
policy content type default style and refresh and each one of those are all like pretty freaking
interesting i think um because with content security policy you can trigger a content security policy
to execute um inside the browser using using that meta tag we see that pretty often that's that's
pretty common um but setting the content type this includes encoding that that's another thing that i
hadn't really thought about before researching for this episode is like you may be able to use
the meta tag to change the encoding for the content body and trigger some xss further down in the page
um if you've got some weird injection points so that's one that i hadn't really thought about
yeah so i just tested this on on safari um let's see what version the latest of our version 16.5.1
and what it does it throws an error so i don't know if it's actually exploitable or maybe you might
need to do some modifications but it does say not allowed to navigate top frame to data url data
colon text html so it does like it's parsing it and it's like skipping over that zero uh zero semicolon
thing yeah uh and it does seem to like try to do it but maybe this is something that they added
recently um as as a fix um because i know that like some of the things that are in this cheat sheet
are definitely for older versions like it talks about like from 65 which is probably that's way out
there five five plus years old yeah yeah for sure and so like it said there used to be a set cookie
instruction which is like oh my gosh that would be lit you know the good old days that's so fun but the way
that i see meta tags used most most um commonly now for exploitation purposes is for this content
security policy stuff and then also primarily for this redirection um piece right because like think
about it it's very hard to get actually i can't even really think of another way to x to redirect a
page with no user interaction with with just html without using javascript right yeah and for what
it's worth that's that works on safari at least i just tested that like the the meta redirect
for the language tag like that works totally fine yeah but redirecting it to a data url it doesn't want
to do yeah so you've definitely got that in your pocket and this can be useful in a bunch of different
scenarios um it can be useful on embedded devices it can be useful um in inside of headless browsers
um and so uh the open redirect piece you know by the meta tag is really cool and i would love to see
some research surrounding um the content type piece um because i feel like there's definitely
some interesting functionality there i was trying to think about the default style piece um i i couldn't
really come up with anything but it seems weird to me so yeah so i mean there's always the the
scenario that always comes to mind with like style stuff for me is the key like the key press uh like
sniffing where i think that's always been like a really solid attack scenario where if you can eject
styles like you can either you can create a really plausible phishing scenario because you're on an ssl
signed website that's looks completely different and might have different different content and stuff
but you can also do like key like key input like changes where you like hit a background like a
background url or something and i think it still goes through some sort of csp right um but you know
depending on the scenario you can sniff keybinds within the website purely through css yeah which is
just like insane yeah i love i love that bug so much there's been some really cool stuff with that and
i'm actually i'm looking at because like w3 schools is a great resource and i i use them all the time for
yeah for for you know this sort of thing but oh yeah there's also well i'm not i'm just thinking
about it right freaking out oh okay oh geez can you hear me yeah i'm back sorry it like totally went
crazy for just a second okay cool um yeah so i i was just thinking about this right now like as we were
talking about css a couple years ago there was a pro a project that came out called doom nukem css and it's
a full implementation of doom that's written in html and css no way and maybe it uses typescript
too i don't actually i don't actually know but i'm pretty i've if i recall correctly i could have
sworn it was like all css which is like the craziest thing but it looks like there's a decent
amount of typescript in here i might be wrong well gareth you know gareth hayes you know we mentioned
him a couple times on this um on this episode his personal website if you go to his twitter profile
and you click his bio link that's like a css based like freaking interactive game masterpiece
of a website and it's just kind of like an ongoing project for him and i'm like wow that's like such
a cool hobbyist activity of like just mastering css stuff and he and he tweets about like css
related quirks all the time which i think is really helpful as well yeah what is it gareth hayes
dot code uk yeah check it out yeah oh man this is while you're checking out i wanted to know this
is exactly what i was thinking of actually yeah yeah so there's some really crazy stuff you can do with
css um with just pure css which is nuts but um i what i was going to say before my computer started
losing its mind um was that i went to w3 schools and i was it says that there's only four attributes that
can go inside of or values that can go inside of the http equiv um header or i mean html attribute
um but actually i'm looking at some other stuff and i think there's more so like i've seen other
references to window.target and content encoding as well so i'm actually after this episode i'm going
to go try to suss that out because um i think there might be some other things we can put in http equiv
that could really really mess with the you know the dom um that's being loaded up so definitely
some cool stuff i also wonder if there's like undocumented features and still like functionality
because i feel like a lot of browsers will create just like they'll create weird edge cases with like
that they use internally um that are only really designed to be used by them that may not adhere
directly to the html spec or what the public spec says should be possible but is actually
still possible and you know it's important to remember that just because the spec says that
it should be this way doesn't mean that it's actually implemented that way for sure yeah yeah
there's definitely some some i'm looking through right now there's some weird some weird stuff there
so i'm going to check that out afterwards um but for for those of you listening right now what we can
what we can confirm right here is it's it is helpful for exploitation in a content security policy
scenario if you want to make the content security policy stricter to lock out like for example a um
like for example if they're loading up a js library that does purification or something like that
then it's helpful there and then it's also possible to use it for a a no additional click
or redirect if you have an html injection so that's helpful as well yeah yeah super cool um so the other
thing that we were going to talk about here was the base tags um and base tags this is something that
that i didn't know about till recently i think these have to be in inside the head um uh sort of
section within the browser um or within the dom so i'm not sure how often we're getting injections up
in there um but yeah there's some really cool stuff you can do with this um essentially it allows you to
turn relative urls into uh you know fully qualified urls with your domain which is super helpful for um
you know hijacking stuff further down in the flow of the page uh and and maybe even bypassing csp in some
scenarios um yeah some i don't know if you can nonce an external import but um yeah that would be
that would be helpful in that scenario yeah i'm just testing this one on safari as well just to
double check because i'm pretty sure you're right that it has to be almost certain it has to be in the
in the head yeah yeah i think i think it has to be um uh but yeah i i didn't know about this and
this is just another really cool piece that you can you can use an html injection it doesn't it
doesn't have to be in the head what maybe safari is doing something weird uh yeah this could be
something that's doing doing weird but i did just double check and in my body element i put a base href
and a script tag and it is trying to load it from the base url wow that's in the body tag that i stand
corrected man yeah this has a lot of power this element um and html like we mentioned html injections
can be kind of tricky but this is definitely something that you can use to kind of try to
turn the tides in your favor headers chrome is doing it too i've nerd sniped joel is just like staring
wide-eyed at his at his computer right now like chrome does it too so yeah if you put the base tag
tag even in the body yeah dude i i could have sworn that it was a head only thing yeah but okay yeah
so a base uh base tag anywhere um will change where it tries to load from even if it's in the body
very solid man all right next up we've got a clip from episode 27 this is where we were talking about
esoteric web vulnerabilities and this one specifically is talking about client-side path traversals this is
a very interesting bug from just i was i was talking about client-side path traversals you
were talking about secondary context path traversals um but we got the we got the conversation done
either way so hope you guys enjoy this one um next one that i had on the list was client-side path
traversal now this one's a little bit weird because you'd think of path traversal normally as a you know
server-side sort of thing you're you're putting something in either a query parameter or a path
and you directly in your url and you're getting to access to some path that you that you didn't
previously have access to by using some iteration of dot dot slash or combination of dot dot slashes
right um the client-side path traversal occurs when you are able to inject via a query parameter or a
hash or something in the user's browser so you know the users click the link or you've redirected the user
to a specific spot um and that page is uh loading a resource based off of your attacker-based input so let's
say for example you redirect them to google.com slash example slash one two three four and they try
to load a css page that that's like slash css slash one two three four dot css right so your one two three
four from the path is being taken and put into a resource that's being loaded then you know if it's
url decoding it and stuff like that you can try to use some um path traversal sequences to hit a
different part of the application hopefully hit a redirect and get yourself a full css injection on
that page which as as we all know from listening to other episodes of critical thinking can result in
some very critical stuff um so uh that's sort of what i had on client-side path traversal you got
any other thoughts on that joel yeah i mean this isn't a client-side path traversal but i think one
of the things that's kind of closely related to this that i really like as a class of bug and this is
kind of it's not really talked about a ton but i think it's it's like path traversal through id and
oftentimes i see this with like there's a post request that includes an id in it for example there's say
it's a posting a json body one of the parameters is id in the body and it's a uuid or something
well oftentimes you can put uuid slash dot dot slash some other arbitrary path some arbitrary
internal path or something and that just gets fully concatenated into an internal request and it's it's
like in the line of ssrf kind of srf slash path reversal but it's a really really interesting
technique and i see it exploited all the time like all over the place it's something
that i now regularly check for whenever i see an id being sent is let me just try putting a dot dot
slash and then like the same id after it and just see if that still works because that's often a
really good indicator of whether or not it's working and that's kind of um i don't know it's it's not
quite esoteric it's a little more common but it's like a weird um route for exploiting like srfs and
kind of a server-side path traversal if you want to call it that um and i think it it deserves being
mentioned alongside this yeah for sure man i i've seen those all the time and excuse me they're
very impactful bugs if you can get them to work especially if you understand what api is being
hit in the back end or you have some introspection to that through the error or something like that
those are some crazy crazy bugs so and and then just to clarify the reason why you're saying put so
let's say we've got id or uuid equals you know one two three four dash whatever then you put a slash
at the end you put a dot dot slash right so that would delete the id you just put in right yeah and
then you put the same id again so that that path is should be normalizing to the same thing it was
without having the any of the path traversals in there right right and you can imagine this in
in the back end scenarios basically like one service is hitting another service the way it does that
that microservices yeah yeah microservices hitting it through an http request and it goes you know
other internal service dot host slash id or whatever slash api slash get slash id or something right
however you want to imagine how it's being put in there and then if you're giving it a full value and
it's not being sanitized and that's just being chucked onto the end of that url your path traversal is
going to affect that internal microservice call and be able to hit other api endpoints and other things
within that other service that you may not have been intended to to hit and i i see so much impact
approved from these all the time it's really insane some of the biggest uh baddest vulnerabilities i've
ever seen are caused by this and it's something that seems so simple and straightforward so if you're
not checking for that be sure to check for that because it's it's again it's it's not quite an easy
win but it's it's it definitely gives you a lot of leverage yeah and i think it's systemic on the
targets as well normally because the target is using a microservices based architecture so if you find
one you're likely to find lots of other unique issues as well with their own unique fixes um and
so i'll actually also link in the in the notes for this episode um that uh there's a blog post by sam
curry and i uh that did let's see when did we i'm not sure this is a long time ago that we had done this
um yeah i mean sam is like the king of this type of yeah he's the one who i like learned it off of
and i see so many crazy impactful bugs that are that are shown by him using this uh i i wasn't sure
which ones i i should even talk about because i know like some of them are not public so yeah
if you have a good example okay it's public there's a blog post so we'll link it in the description if
you haven't seen it that's great but um joel you we we we got off topic there the one that i'm trying
to talk about here is the client side path reversal which is different very notably different so don't
very notably different yes um this is something that happens in the user's browser i mentioned yeah
this happens in style sheets but it also happens in js files and it can also happen just in in fetch
and ajax requests right so requests that are being sent by the page via javascript and those are very
impactful as well because if you can traverse in a context where it's trying to like let's say it's
sending a post request to like you know load your news feed or whatever right if you can control that
path and you can hit you know make it hit like slash delete account and that delete account doesn't
require any you know parameters then you can force user to just delete their account i've found this bug
before um and so definitely be on the lookout there's a lot of different implications it can result in
um css injection it can result in xss it can result in um this sort of c surf sort of outcome um and then
the other thing that i i i don't know how much of an issue this still is but um there used to be this
thing called 401 injection where you can inject a uh you know a prompt where it would pop up and they
would ask the user to type in their credentials right and then that prompt was actually coming from your
website but it was on the page that uh you know you injected into um that used to be a bug i don't
i i didn't get a chance to check it before this episode to see whether it's still active or not
but um if that could also be a potential outcome from this sort of uh client-side path traversal if
you can find an open redirect and redirect to your own site where you serve a 401 yeah i do wonder if
that's still a thing i remember that that class of vulnerability but i don't actually know know if it's
still accessible that's that's with like uh realm like authentication stuff right yeah yeah and i'm
i'm pretty confident it's it's possible in at least one of the major browsers i just can't remember
which one it is so we'll have to check that out i've got some good guesses and it's probably not chrome
yes it's definitely not chrome
sweet next up for also from episode 27 is cookie bombing and cookie jar overflows this is some really
helpful content surrounding using cookies to assist in exploitation chains all right next one cookie
bombing have you have you heard of have you heard of cookie bombing slash do you do cookie bombing joel
i i before i get put on the list here uh uh so i i hadn't really i the i'd heard of the name
and i understand like the concept um but until i actually read through file descriptors um slides
about this specifically now it definitely clicks and i would kind of tie it in with the next one
that we were going to talk about which is cookie jar overflow but basically these two classes are um
exploiting just like sort of native browser behavior around how cookies are set and sent and so oftentimes
there have been new security features that have been added to like how cookies work for example http only
um or site secure or whatever um and that make it so that they're only accessible within certain
contexts and they're only sent within certain contexts and you know if it's http only then your
javascript can't read and write it but that's fine because sometimes you control a web server that
is doing that over http instead of doing that over javascript and so with cookie bombing for example you can
set multiple cookies for the same host on different paths and when they get sent the browser
doesn't distinguish whether or not you know oftentimes well maybe it does well i mean i mean
it's supposed to the paths the paths piece um you can use the different paths to bomb specific end
points so like you said you know the the this is abusing a sort of browser level problem with cookie
management which is if you send too many cookies uh the browser will still send them to the to the server
but the server will sort of i guess this is sort of a server-side issue then the server is going to
freak out and be like okay whoa whoa this request is way too big please please stop right and it's
gonna i forget what status code it sends it's it's some 400 status code um but it freaks out and it
doesn't like that right um and so you can set you know you can set enough cookies that the browser will
happily send along which essentially dos is your access to a specific website until you delete your
cookies right um and you literally do that just by setting all right cookie one equals 9999 a's cookie
two equals 9999 a's you know and then like do that until you've blown up the whole request right
and um and that will result in the whatever user's browser you're you're setting this in uh not being
able to access the target the target website until they clear their cookies um and this can be particularly
tricky here's here's a here's a fun one here if you do this on a sub part of a website that
is not the top url because what what people will do sometimes is they can't access the website they'll
delete the cookies for the specific website that they're on right which is their top url but let's
say use for example you cookie bombed the api.domain right the api.domain.com the that's never in the
user's top level browser so if they try to delete their cookies for that website then they can't do it
right without without going in there and actually deleting all of their cookies which is kind of a pain
in the ass because it it logs you out of literally every single website yeah um so this is this is a
really cool volume and you can do this with just a gadget that sets allows you to inject a cookie
on the website which is fairly common um and this is also a great way for you to um show uh an effect
to availability uh which ups your cvss score um and it really helps with like stuff like subdomain
takeovers to show impact yeah yeah there's actually a cool tool idea just thought of right now as
we're saying that which would be something that basically you could plug in your existing cvss
score or maybe like say you have a bug and it meets certain criteria within cvss and then the
tool would tell you if you could get the if you could change this one factor it would take your bug
from a medium to a high or a medium to a crit or something that's a great idea so so you'd have you
could put in your cvss score and then it'll tell you okay your easiest escalations are going to be
all right if you can figure out how to affect availability just a little bit you know maybe
try cookie bombing or something like that dude that's a great idea someone's got to build that
yeah yeah uh not us though yeah i got too much going on yeah critical thinking community please
please take that and run somebody make that tool even if it takes four years big work yeah at big work
no that's great um and the the other thing that i was gonna say um specifically on app cache
erbin um on cookie bombing is you can use it with stuff as well like like app cache um because what
will happen if you define an app cache on a specific page uh if there's an error that occurs at the
browser level uh it will sub in a different content so it's perfect for cookie bombing and i've seen this
i've seen franz abuse this i've seen file descriptor abuse this and he actually mentions it in his talk
entitled the cookie monster in your browsers which i think was the talk you were mentioning earlier um and he
also mentions how you can use it to get it to not consume a loth tokens because you can keep on the
specific a loth endpoint right yeah and this is like a lot called such an interesting attack vector
so yeah i guess if you basically cookie bomb and it sets too many cookies the request will fail
but the requests the outbound request will still contain like the credentials or whatever in the url
and so you can because it's like a failed request it doesn't hit like iframe options
i guess is that correct well so there there's some there's some intricacies like that but the one
the one that's really you know helpful in this scenario is like and it can help you avoid iframe
options and some csp stuff as well but in this scenario you you're when as soon as that that code
lands on the page where the callback is it gets used and consumed right so even if you have a reference
to that window and with an xss or something like you can't consume you can't get to that token in time
because it's gonna you're gonna lose the race every time and it's gonna consume the last token and you
can't get account takeover but if you cookie bomb the endpoint where that oauth code is getting returned
to when it goes to that page it's gonna fail but you because you're the same origin you can still reach
into that page grab the you know um window location dot href and pull the code out of there
which would allow you to get escalate your xss to ato it's just such a great technique i love it yeah
that's awesome yeah yeah um on cook so then like tendential yeah the cookie jar overflow which is
kind of similar in like sending too many cookies or like yeah sort of overflowing how the browser
is behaving but you actually have a whole tool for this which i did not know about called check
cookie jar overflow i don't know what it's what you call it but it's a layout on your domain yeah it's a
link apps.renorator.dev you guys can check it out this is just kind of it's just kind of like if you
click on it it's kind of like just a scrappy little website with like a freaking um apache you
know yeah it's it's literally 20 20 lines of html including the script and essentially um what it
allows so i actually before prepping for this episode i was like all right let me you know i
was prepared for this episode i'm like you know i i'm gonna drop some knowledge i'm gonna you know
show them all these cool like weird esoteric web bones and then i get in there and i and i was
researching for cookie bombing and i find this cookie jar overflow thing i'm like what the heck
is that i've never even heard of that and so i found it and i think it was on the site hacker
yeah hacktricks which is really cool like that's a great website by the way yeah did we talk about
this last episode too we might have but what hack tricks yeah yeah but again this is like one of those
like informational type documentation websites that we talked about where this type of resource is
something that like keep it in your bookmarks and just like if you're ever stuck on something
check all of the ones that you have bookmarked because oftentimes there'll be some like weird
edge stuff or just some like really interesting techniques that somebody has documented somewhere
that you can take advantage of to escalate your vulnerability to the next level yeah there's so many
awesome like just weird things in this hack tricks dot xyz um website so i'll do my best to sort of go
in and digest some of that and and put it up back into the podcast um in an auditory format but when
i was prepping for the the like for the cookie bombing i ran across this cookie jar overflow which
is really cool and i actually um had i known about this um at the last life hacking event i would have
been able to save a friend a lot of time because he had to go uh down this this path to get rid of this
cookie that he needed to be gone um and uh he could have just used this technique um and it would
have just he would have been able to get it gone in just a second so the technique just to be clear
is um you essentially just set a bunch of cookies in the browser for a specific domain and each domain
has a limit on how many cookies can be associated with it in the browser that's the cookie jar and the
cookie jar limit um and so if you if you exceed that limit cookies start getting deleted oldest first
so you can edge out the other cookies in the user's browser even if you don't know the name of that
cookie so let's say for example you have a cookie um you know session uh auth session xyz random string
equals whatever their session token is right you don't know what that random string is so you can't
overwrite that cookie and if it's an http only cookie you can't access it from the javascript side
even if you can set cookies right so you need that cookie gone so you can do a session fixation
um and how do you how are you gonna get rid of it because you don't know the name of it
right so um this is a cool technique you can use to do that by setting a bunch of cookies overflowing
the cookie jar and then being able to use your own values um and one of the things i thought was really
interesting is you can edge out http only cookies even from a non-htp only context which i think is
really cool and seems like a little bit of an issue right yeah well i mean and again this is like
weird behavior that's kind of intended but also not intended like yeah you know it it abuses like one
two functionalities that both need to exist at the same time and they kind of collide with each other
tangentially right where it's like http only shouldn't be able to be set by javascript but if
you set a bunch of other cookies with javascript eventually you'll have too many cookies and the http
only cookies will just get removed and like yeah you know that what the browser is going to just have
infinite memory no like you can't right so like these two things have to both exist and there's
no real easy compromise there so it's super super interesting behavior and one of those things that
you know have it documented keep it in the back of your brain and then when you need it you'll have it
yeah for sure so we'll add some links down below the little um sort of tool that i that you mentioned
before that you saw in the doc that was just something that i sort of scraped together to help people
understand where their cookie jar overflow limit is in the browser so you guys can check it out we'll
link it down below it's apps.ryanrader.dev cookie or slash check cookie jar overflow.html in camel case
of course you know probably easier to just click the link you're welcome just click the link in the
description yeah um but essentially if you go to that and you click on it it will set a bunch of cookies
and tell you where your cookie jar limit is in your browser um i ran it in chrome in prep for this
episode and it puts it at 180 cookies um the range for this is between i think 150 to 180 but every
time i've run it i've gotten 180 so um you know you should be able to do it pretty easily yeah and maybe
as some off off the pod research i would be curious if this matters more uh like the length of the cookie
if that matters at all or if it's just purely number of cookies do you know i think it's just pure
number of cookies because i was just setting let me take a look at the code really quickly here
you say off the pod research and then you know we're going to do it right away yeah we're going
to look right now yeah no it's just it's just you know check and then the index equals the index so
i'm just saying check one equals one check two equals two and that sort of thing and it's overflowing
at 180 so i i think i think it's just a number of cookies thing all right this next clip from episode
44 is really from a lhe takeaway episode but there's some really cool tips and tricks in here
specifically around cross environment authentication specifically specifically how you can use
authentication tokens from one environment on another environment potentially get access and bypass all
sorts of access controls i just also wanted to talk about some other concepts that have kind of been
banging around in my head from the live hacking events that we've been to over the past couple months
um and you know there's just been lots of good discussions with hackers and and one of the ones
that that came into my my brain was this concept of shared secrets across environments you know um and
specifically jwt related things um if you have a a jwt signing secrets that's shared across multiple
environments and you're giving people you're allowing people to register on one environment with an email
and then you can use that same token because it passes validation on a different app you know i have
no idea what you're talking about right now i've never seen that exact i've never seen that exact bug
uh on oh really oh maybe well i was talking to someone specific about this sort of bug um you know at a
live hacking event but yeah essentially the bug was that you know there was a stage environment you
could sign up for you'd get a jwt you could use that same jwt on the prod environment um so let's say
you've got an account registered you know joel joel.com right i could go to the staging environment
register joel.joel.com you know if there's not email i am being sarcastic right now because there
is i i don't know if you're like playing in on this but yes there was a this exact same thing on
it wasn't staging but it was just that you could like log into certain apps and then any app within
that same like they use the same auth mechanism like middleware whatever across all their things yeah you
see it you know you see it at at on various targets uh you know i wasn't i mean what was that sarcasm
was that like are you saying because it exists because that was almost the exact bug that i was
just talking about as well with stuff it was the same target and it was realizing that bug oh what the
heck i did not hear about this this is crazy okay okay i didn't yeah yeah yeah so there was an off
bypass to get into one of these tools yeah this is more prevalent than expected i think because this is
this is you know multiple live hacking events over the past year that that has had you know this issue
pop up on a hardened target like a live hacking event target so definitely something we see and
was sort of on my radar because we talked about cookie monster in the past right that uses sort of
um you know that kind of has a similar situation where it's like okay you know maybe you can forge this
jwt but the reuse of that jwt wasn't really on my radar until this past year quite as much yeah and
honestly like from a from an engineering perspective i totally see why it's happening
because there's more and more push to centralize all these sorts of off mechanisms into one place
and have like a single single mechanism that's doing all the authentication in a standardized way
which means that you have more risk for somebody to be able to issue an auth token that's just
valid unless that single central auth mechanism is really really strictly properly checking like where did
this come from is it specifically authorized for this other application that they're trying to use it on
more than is it valid and is it like validly signed and all that kind of stuff because all that stuff
could be true but it could be for some other service and it could still pass it's actually
similar to the uh to the thing we were just talking about uh you know before when when you're reusing
tokens across different different providers too right like the the facebook thing where where they're
not checking the app id associated with it right um because it's actually a token for a different
provider but you know it kind of all checks out so uh there's there's definitely reoccurring themes
that we see across these authentication bugs which the more and more you familiarize yourself with them
you'll you'll start looking for those uh attack vectors which that's been kind of a way i've i've
grown as a hacker and over the past couple years is like um authentication related bugs can be really
scary and sometimes i feel like i'm forced on that route because the other scope is so you know it's like
all right you might as well just look at auth and then when you do some crazy bugs can come out of
that so yeah and it's weird because like i almost never look at off a lot of the time because it's
such a weird yeah it's such a weird flow and you can end up sinking a lot of time there yeah and it's
like a lot of times it's like a weird setup stage where there's very like limited restricted amount of
data and the program even if you submit it they'll be like oh well this is just during the registration
flow so unless the impact is like elsewhere within the application oftentimes it doesn't even like
really count or it's not a high enough impact um but yeah like you said when you get backed into those
corners where where it's a tight scope i mean we just saw at the last event lots of off stuff that was
just like you know small scope where do you look but you know you you also look at the at the hackers
that pop crits on a regular basis right you look at samurb you look at oxacb you look at some of
these guys that make a habit of looking at auth every single time they they always pop stuff man
they somehow manage yeah and so um yeah that's something that i've sort of resolved to look into
a little bit more um and and on that you know on that note uh i i was going to talk a little bit about
one of the uh sort of successes i've had in this arena which is um uh finding where i guess looking at
auth which is multi-factor authentication bypasses and there's lots of like you know super crappy
multi-factor authentication bypasses where you can like just navigate to the page or like you know
there's some some some um you know other tricks you can do but one of the things that i kind of wanted
to highlight is like especially when you've got a flow where there's multiple multi-factor devices
like hey you know do i want to send a text message to the phone or do i want to get an email or do i want
to get a push you know these systems get really complex and these ob objects these devices they're
just objects in the application and they're vulnerable to stuff like idor just like every other object in
the in the application could be right so um you know i remember taking a deep dive at a target one time
and and kind of um looking at this flow and finding an idor in the multi-factor authentication flow which
just allowed me to use an attacker controlled device to authenticate into the victim's account
and and you could use that to get account takeover via the password reset flow and it was like i can't
believe that this actually worked so yeah you'd think that i would i would learn my lesson the simplest
thing you know to like keep actually look at authentication more often but you know sometimes
it just doesn't sink in that's awesome that's awesome and you didn't even say the word rate
limiting i'm so proud of you oh yeah that's true rate limiting yeah i said dumb multi-factor bypasses
like just navigating to the thing anyway i was waiting for you to say rate limited because that's
like the that's like the go-to mfa bypass which is that you can brute force otp codes it's screwed so
many companies too if you can figure out a way to to you know yeah definitely facebook pays a lot of
money for that yeah yeah they've paid multiple mid to high five figure crits i believe for that that
bug that specifically yep ridiculous all right next up we've got a clip from episode 47 uh in which we
talked about csp research iframe hopping and client-side shenanigans this clip is particularly
talking about the open-faced iframe sandwich a technique which will allow you to exploit uh excesses in
subdomains that aren't necessarily attached to the main domain hope you enjoy this one one thing that
i wanted to share that we mentioned on the on the discord and i realized wasn't really sort of common
knowledge for people is this sort of concept of an iframe sandwich uh and it's not really an iframe
sandwich but it's sort of like an open iframe sandwich okay and and so uh this is something that
you can do because i've mentioned before on the pod and in other mediums that if you have a target that
iframe is in a subdomain okay so let's say one of the one of the the first time i actually fully
exploited this the scenario was uh my target domain i framed in a marketing subdomain where you could
control your email preferences or whatever right okay not a huge impact in that scenario but i did
something cool with it with oauth stuff and got atl um no big deal yeah but um uh in that scenario the
iframe domain which is different from the different domain from the primary domain if you can pop an xss
on that iframed domain you can do some cool okay so what you can do is from an attacker and keep in
mind this domain is is iframed so normally it has um you know iframe allow configurations so what you
can do from your attacker controlled page you can iframe in and do an invisible iframe to that subdomain
where you have the xss pop the xss get js control okay then from the attacker controlled page pop open
a new tab to the the victim domain that you would like to attack and that victim domain has the xss
vulnerable subdomain iframe 10 right and then what you can do is you can reach from the iframe on the
attacker controlled page up to the attacker page over to the the victim domain and then down into the
xss domain um on that page by using different frames and because you control um js on the iframe on your
page you can modify the content of the iframe on the victim domains page right that's iframed into the
victim domains page and you can affect that content so let's say in that scenario you can rewrite the
content with like you know uh something that might could leak tokens something that could you know you
could put even a uh you know sort of a phishing thing in there and that sort of thing is is normally
accepted in my experience because you're affecting the integrity of the in scope application by modifying
the contents of a domain that they are iframing into their website um and and so i kind of call this an
iframe sandwich it's not really you know when iframes used to be a little bit more permissive you could do
some cooler stuff with that but um just making sure you understand how frames work and and how what
kind of stuff you can access using parent using opener using the frames array yeah yeah on let's
say victim.com you have one tab victim.com right inside it they have vulnerable.com yes
yeah vulnerable.com or you know vulnerable.victim.com or something but it's okay
okay and vulnerable.com no one does it should do yeah so now the nexus says you have an exit
inside an iframe on uh on the on the well not exactly okay so let me let me break it down a little
bit a little bit better you've got your you've got two frames or two pages two tabs with iframes in them
okay okay one is an attacker control or an attacker page and one of them is the victim page both of them
have an iframe to um access has vulnerable domain right okay using the x uh you can't control the
the path in that is iframe into the victim's domain so that's always going to be iframe to wherever the
victim says it should go right okay but on the attacker controlled page you you can control it so
you pop xss through that reach back up through the attacker controlled page reach over to the the tab
that's opened up uh the other iframe page reach into the iframe and modify the content does that
make sense okay yeah so it's almost backwards instead like you're modifying the the victim page from the
attacker page exactly because it's the same iframe within both because it's the same origin yeah right
same origin so you can communicate with iframes of the same origin in a different tab is there a
better way to explain this because i i had the trouble you explain the other way around it was a
little confusing because it was kind of like you get an xss within this iframe and then you set up
your own page like i think the way you just described it now is better where basically you have two pages
they both iframe the same url you have an xss in both of them but you can easily pop it from your
attacker page which then you can use that context to communicate with the context they both iframe in
the other page you iframe they both iframe the same domain but probably a different url if it's a
reflected xss yeah like you know like there's no saying that like maybe on victim.com right like that you'd be able to
actually pop it through the url or something maybe it's a complex attack scenario it doesn't really matter
because all you need is control over that iframe context with the same origin right yeah exactly
exactly and as long as you control you're running js execution right on that on that origin
and you have a path to reach the the other frame right in this scenario it would be
the parent oh that's why you open it up the other tab iframe is that why you open it from victim.com
why you have to open it from victim.com no no no well you you have you have attacker controlled
page with the with the xss in that would you just open the victim page from your attacker page
exactly got it that one understood yeah and then you hop over there and modify it
um man maybe i should uh maybe let me let me make a note here what what we need a cardboard box
diagram from i'll i'll uh i'll draw a little draw a diagram for iframe sandwich um i'll draw a little
diagram and put it on the screen for those of you watching so basically you you open attacker.com
attacker.com opens a new tab with victim.com they both iframe the same url you pop the xss from your
attacker.com in in the iframe which can then communicate with the iframe in the other tab on victim.com
and then you can either control the content you can do whatever you want within that iframe
exactly yeah and and you know um depending on the refer policy and stuff like that you might be able
to leak uh you know you uh a lot parameters and that sort of thing um so all sorts of cool stuff you
can do with that it's a good way to take an xss in a subdomain that's you know maybe not even in
scope or less important and make it affect the primary domain and increase your impact
next up also from episode 47 there's a super hot topic in the industry right now called js hoisting
and we decided to discuss that i of course got nerd sniped and was getting distracted trying to
figure out how this all works so you're not going to want to miss this one so i i i'm going down a
path of trying to represent things from an audio perspective it's going to be tricky but okay let's
say we had a fun an injection at a place in the js where it was x dot y where neither x nor y were
defined okay can you control them no you can't control them they're they're not defined and then
it's a function call so it's calling the function x dot y the first parameter is one there's a comma
and then you are injecting okay and you can inject anything you want except for script text you have to
stay inside the script right um how do you get this to resolve because as soon as it reads the line
it's going to say x is undefined uh you know or y is undefined can't access read a property on undefined
error and then your code is never going to run um and so i was looking at this i was like i know that
there's a way to exploit this i can't figure out what it was and i tried actually the solution that
ended up working but i was missing one stupid little piece um and the answer to this problem
is something called js hoisting have you heard of js hoisting joel i don't know if i've heard of
the term but if you explain it to me i might i might have heard of it yeah so the term is js hoisting
and it's essentially the concept that functions in js defined using and some other objects as well but
mostly for this case functions defined using the function keyword despite where they are in the flow
will be hoisted to the top of the of the script execution flow so if you define a function at
the very bottom using the function keyword of a script tag and you call that function above where
that function is defined it'll work because the function definition is getting moved up to the top
of um the the script okay so in this scenario what we were able to do was define the function x okay
and uh and what that would do is it would hoist the definition up to the top so now the variable x
now contains a valid function okay so when you try to access the property y on x you don't get an error
but you get y is undefined then it will attempt to call the the undefined uh y because of the function
call and when it does that it will parse the parameters that are being passed into that function
and at that point when it parses the parameters you can do a function call in the parameters themselves
um and that will get executed before it attempts to call y which will inevitably fail because you can't
call undefined um and in that way we were able to get arbitrary script execution and pop it into an xss
because of this concept called js wasting so i wanted to shout that out there because we're big fans of
of uh that kind of crazy edge fringe javascript here on the pod um and i'm not i wasn't even sure
yeah i i i feel like most people haven't heard of it so i i would be surprised if you had heard of that
joel yeah i was i was just testing some things around he's got a he's got a handheld mic and he's
trying to type and speaking to them yeah i was testing some things around this uh to see if there's a
better way and i think there might be without having to break out of the whole thing all right
this is like classic joel nerd sniped right here okay all right joel reign it in reign it in bring
it back to the pod okay what i was gonna say is okay he's still freaking looking at it i am still
freaking looking at it i was just gonna that's fine okay um yeah so the js hoisting thing it seems that
that so context is important right um yeah basically my thought was like maybe you could
do this without having to break out of the function um but even if you define x within the parameters
it doesn't work because it's right within the con like so you can never get evaluated because it fails
right in the beginning right so like you you uh tweeted out uh a similar like an xss challenge like a
while ago and had to do with essentially in javascript there's a behavior where you can use commas
to provide multiple statements and you can assign variables to the last variable the last thing that
is returned in that comma sequence yeah and you can abuse that in a similar way here um where you can
use that for like you know one comma whatever and you can just within your parameters you can do the
same thing um but because it's within that context of it's already trying to call it it seems that it has
to be like what you said like you have to define it because it's going to try and call it before it
evaluates um well it's going to try to read the the yeah like the object itself so it's going to say
does the object exist then it gets the parameters then it passes them into the function call exactly
and when it tries to say hey i need to get the x or the y property of x then x is undefined then you
can't get a property of undefined and then that'll error right um so shout out to bit k um and to johan
and a couple of the other people that i think carl also corell origin um also got it um and was able
to to exploit this so uh definitely i appreciate the the help there and i learned a lot about javascript
that day because then i had to do of course i had to deep dive js hoisting so there's a bunch of um you
can do it with variables you can do it with classes but the cool thing about functions is it's not just
um the thing doesn't just get defined it gets sort of it's initialized yeah it's an actual object
like i'm pretty sure the reasoning for this was that like way back in the day there was a there
was a historical problem with programming languages where if you define something after it was used
it couldn't be called and i think this was most common with like c and c plus plus and stuff but if
you had a function that was like if your main function essentially wasn't at the end of your program
then you couldn't like call anything else because it didn't know it existed i think this was maybe
why header files i don't know i'm not an expert on this but essentially like that's part of what jas
is trying to solve here is that like if you call something before it's defined it should still be
able to call it even if because it's defined it's just that like it it does some restructuring and like
i don't know yeah yeah it's super interesting um well like reworking that existing behavior to to
work in your in your favor yeah the other interesting thing with this is that um
it doesn't it doesn't work for variables to find the functions so for example if you did var
x equals function blah blah blah blah blah and defined it that way like you're defining a variable
pointing to a function rather than using the function keyword then it won't work but if you use the function
keyword um as the primary expression in that that line of code then um it will it will hoist it so lots
of cool lots of cool things there i was just talking to my my brother-in-law the other day who's a
programmer and we were talking he was saying he freaking hates javascript and i was like man i
love javascript because javascript there's so many ways to get everything done and there's so many quirks
to the language it's like a hacker's dream it really is it really is yeah it's super interesting that um
if you define it as a variable it works but doesn't work what do you mean so when you when you do
like if you do var x equals function afterwards after the call it'll say cannot read properties
of oh no it doesn't work sorry i misread it i misread it my bad sorry well sometimes it'll
so there is something you can do with var because var will hoist the the definition to the top or the
initialization no not that the definition to the top but not the initialization there we go um or maybe
it's the declaration that's what i'm looking for yeah it'll hoist the declaration but it will not
hoist the initialization um and so that's a little bit of a of a quirky thing there and with that we're
on to the interview section we've got a lot of great guests on this list and first up is sean yo from
asset node we had a great conversation with him surrounding everything recon and specifically the clip
we took for today is diving into what should be your primary key in your recon infrastructure should
it be ips should it be subdomains i think sean has a really nuanced answer so i hope you enjoy it
well for example one of the things that i i i and we were talking about earlier today with uriota was
um you know dividing out your domains and your ip addresses logically and and not making your your
subdomain your primary key right yeah like that was my when i that was my biggest architectural mistake
i made when i built my recon system was i was like i was obsessed with subdomains yeah i was like subdomain
is is the end all be all but really at the end of the day it all goes down to i you know ip addresses
i shouldn't say that but it mostly all goes down by well i mean that's a good point because i think
so this is the kind of discussion i want to have is like you know what what are those those mistakes
like focusing on subdomains instead of focusing ip addresses as the lowest level of logical
entities and you know mapping those because yeah i think it also comes to like what carbon recon are
you doing yeah and i think subdomains is fine because a lot of things like subdomains is the
easiest identifiable way of looking at something yeah the reason you say ip addresses is relevant
is because there's a whole bunch of assets and like what we yeah what we consider assets that might
not have a subdomain associated right right like companies like or just a subdomain that you don't
know yeah yeah they don't like they exist on the internet you just can't see them yet but there's
also like a whole separate set of pitfalls like when you start to go to that level because ips rotate
like things subdomains get reassigned so like you might have an ip address that's stored and then you're
scanning you're like oh my god there's a new service on this yeah it's exploitable and it turns out it
belongs to somebody else like it's come it's not even theirs and then you report it to the company and
they're like we don't we don't own this ip yeah yeah that's true i mean yeah i i think it all it
all depends on and this is kind of what we were talking about earlier sort of correlation factors
and i think that could definitely be a new logical entity in a recon structure system you know like
like you have this this domain and you've got that you know database what you know about that domain
and you've got this subdomain meaning and or fqdn and then you've got this ip address and then you've
got some sort of relationship between the two of them and how that's correlated it could be a dns
an entry that correlates them it could be a tls you know sni you know it could be you know um historical
data it could be you know what what else could it be i'm trying to think what do you think i've been
modeling over this idea for a couple years yeah tried to implement this at astronaut but use case
is very nuanced right yeah so yeah when you start getting into more and more cloud native apps the ways
you identify what you consider like an asset starts to change very differently yeah right in a very
traditional old school setting will probably be like we have ip addresses on servers and that's
it we might give them a sub domain but when you get to like the other end of the spectrum uber starts
routing things based on your sub path um and if you want to be more specific yeah uber starts routing
things based on your sub path in a specific geo location yeah right so even if you hit the same ip
address with the same sub domain same sni same path you'll be hitting two different data centers that
might be running different versions of your app yeah right that's true even further it might be getting
feature flagged and routed to another version of the app based on your user id right and all of
these means that at the end of the day the app you're looking at might not even be the same one
uh you might be getting like a china version of the uber app versus a american version of the uber
app sure or even you might be getting a beta uber app versus the production app right and i think
factoring all of these in into like what you call this correlation yeah probably is overkill for most
people um yeah but i want it to be perfect but you want to well how about this every single company you
create a unique correlation right so you build your mental model you grab cosmon back and you ask him
how does employ their apps right and then you work backwards from there you say i factor it doesn't care
about geolocation they don't care about user id they care about their tenant id they care about this
subdomain whatever but for uber totally different story now we're an entire different paradigm he's
a new correlation method right you want to go to the nth degree you might as well i know it's it's in
in in no i mean you made a perfect point which is that we can't over i mean you you so perfectly
pointed out that that flaw of like this is just going to be way over engineering some of these some
of these things and and at the end of the day you are gonna you are gonna you know run into these
these scenarios where you're like ah it's not perfect but then you gotta you gotta decide is
the trade-off of that fixing that problem actually gonna get me enough bounties to justify the time
that i'm spending on and the answer to that a lot of the time is no i mean sometimes unless you want
to make it your thing yeah like sometimes it's worthwhile hacking around it right you might have
the system that works for 90 of the cases and then you decide okay i'm gonna spend like three weeks
looking at google infrastructure right and now this is its entire own beast that has its own books written on
it right um so i'm just gonna hack together something that's just for this and maybe you'll find that
i've now spent three months on it i understand it enough now i can merge it back into mainline and
feed this across the rest of it yeah you don't have to make everything into your giant monolithic
beast right you can always have smaller pieces that's for something else and then once you sort of
figure out how this works it then comes back naturally into the rest of the work you're doing
in this clip from episode 30 we're talking with shubs all about reverse engineering enterprise
software to find awesome zero days you know it seems like you guys have really found some amazing
bones together and one of the common threads that i noted across all this because i'm i'm not
proficient in this specific area is the use of a dynamic analysis um you know of hooking up a
debugger to it and you know stepping through the code and breaking at certain points and stuff like
that um so you know it can you talk to me a little bit more about that process and how that's
changed your approach to enterprise software yeah for sure i mean debugging is almost necessary when
when we're looking at complex enterprise software sometimes unfortunately it's just not possible
and and we we don't have the installation file or we can't install it like some of the oracle
software that's out there and it's just too tricky to get up and running but right but nine times out of
ten we're looking to get a debugger going because um most of the vulnerabilities that we find they can
be really complex and without a debugger we can't figure out exactly you know what are the variables
at a certain break point how do we manipulate them to get what we want um and and things like that so
these days um most of the projects that we debug from a i guess just from a dynamic analysis perspective
is mostly java and dotnet projects for java we use intellij which is you know you can get the community
addition it works fine out of the box and you can start debugging things for dotnet we use rider and
that's also from jetbrains and that's beautiful like honestly rider you can attach directly to a
process it starts to decompiling everything for you and you can start setting breakpoints quite easily so
for those two languages that's what we use um and i think um when it comes to binary analysis we
obviously we use things like gdb and things like that to do a dynamic analysis um but yeah dylan um
he's honestly um one of the the best researchers that i've ever worked with yeah he's phenomenal
he's great he's he's so great that like sometimes sometimes he's very quiet so sometimes he'll be
quiet for six hours or something and i'll ask him like what's the progress and you're like yeah i got
an orth bypass or a shell or i'll see i'm like dude you could have told me earlier i mean like on the edge
of my seat this whole time you know what i mean so so um so dylan's sometimes quiet but he's he's very
very good i mean his background is very interesting you know if you're not hearing them they're getting
into something you know like yeah yeah yeah and he's he's he's he's just so multi-disciplinary um
he has um such good skills in java and dot net um but he's able to get his hands quite dirty with
uh binary exploitation and analysis as well which is something that's incredibly valuable for us as you
guys have seen like recently the citrix vulnerabilities have come out and where it was like a race to patch
diff them and find the yeah the rce so so without dylan we wouldn't have been able to do that work basically
yeah no he seems like a really valuable addition to the team and and yeah i'm always watching that
that blog very uh you know hopeful for the next one to come out do you have any any teasers for us any
anything you want to tell us about coming up soon yeah yeah for sure there was a metabase pre-auth rce
that was announced um around a week ago so that that's that's the next thing coming up it's done
by myself and an ex-colleague of mine um and we'll be releasing that on august 20. uh that's the slated
so you mentioned that in bug bounty forum for sure but somebody was like hey has anybody somebody
positive like hey does anybody know anything about this metabase rce and shoves just replies yeah acid
have found that yeah it was it was it was a really fun bug and i think people are going to really
enjoy the chain because it was not straightforward and our final exploit payload has like maybe five
or six different tricks in one payload so it's really really fun to fun to see um but but um you
know we'll see there's already chinese researchers that have reproduced the issue and they've posted
tweets of a blurred burp window of the issue so if it drops before august 20 we'll drop our blog post
gotcha wow dude that's awesome i i i love to get the little sneak peek here so thanks for sharing
that that's that's great um so i guess asset notes so going going going to asset note right um just for
those of you that that aren't familiar asset note is the um i guess enterprise security software that um
uh i guess how would i'll let you describe it chubbs uh it's a it's a reconnaissance it started off as
a reconnaissance software uh in order to help you do asset management but it's evolved to so much more
that's right so originally it was an open source project that was just to discover assets as quickly
as possible but now basically what asset does is it discovers all the assets that belong to your
organization on the external attack surface and it continuously monitors it for exposures so it finds
security vulnerabilities and indicators that that that organizations can use but you know like the the
difference between a indie homegrown open source bug bounty tool and an enterprise product that we sell
to the largest enterprises in the world there's just so much in between so so it's different it's just so
different and i you know i mean i see a lot of the the frameworks out there that get released and and
all that sort of stuff and um they're excellent but i just think that like to to sell to enterprises
there's just so many demands that aren't even things that are on people's minds when it comes to building
software um necessarily that that has been very interesting to to work yeah yeah for sure so this
product you know has evolved from recon to to asset management to asset management plus vulnerabilities
and then you know also it seems like this research branch has sort of come out of it now is is that
is that a supplement to the product is that kind of how you're seeing it or uh why did you guys decide
to start this research side of the of the company yeah we we just identified like we because we have
access to all of this reconnaissance data for all of our customers including the technologies right we
identified that we have this really unique opportunity to do security research in a way that's targeted
towards our customers and basically our security research team has maybe like two or three functions
i'd say that the main function is satisfying the needs of our customers when it comes to when a new vulnerability
comes out like the citrix rce like we've we've got plenty of customers that hit us up being like do
you have a check for this and that like for for a very long time i was the single person on the
security research team doing this sort of work but after a certain point there's just so many different
new vulnerabilities that are getting released that we need to stay on top of we needed a research team
it was a natural progression and inside the product like we can't offer a great like exposure scanning
service if we aren't staying on top of the new patches being released new vulnerabilities being
released even new nuclei releases for example we need to stay on top of because there might be
something in there that you know might affect our customers but um the research branch also has a
second um purpose which is marketing and you might have noticed that you know like at asset note we
don't actually invest that much money into traditional marketing like we don't have like crazy campaigns
for traditional marketing we don't have banners at black i've seen any billboards get private rooms
and i mean guys like there might be a time in the future where we have to do that sort of stuff as
the as the company progresses but but until now which is a five-year journey since till now we've relied
on our technical um content to be the biggest marketing that we do and um i can say it's been incredibly
successful um i think from our technical marketing we get probably the most inbound leads i think if
we could attribute them all um which is just you know as a business it's not a bad model yeah no
that's that's amazing go ahead joel yeah so which one would you say sort of drives the other one would
you say that your research team is more like finding new things reversing patches providing those
vulnerabilities like as soon as possible to your customers or your customers prompting you with hey
we heard about this vulnerability or we're affected by this vulnerability can you guys check for it and
then you the research team goes and looks into it so so we we split up our research stream into two
different things which is reactive and proactive and um the reactive stream um is is obviously like
when customers reach out or anything gets released on the internet things like that we prioritize reactive
over proactive but we do definitely still have a lot of time left for proactive research so um i mean
it's it's um for us the number one priority is our customers and what they what their requests are so
we often even work with customers to get access to software that we may not typically have access to
but um that's that's where we spend most of our time is for customer concerns dude that's that's just
what what an amazing service what an amazing product you guys have developed there and i i love that it
it it's roots its origins are in security research and in a thorough understanding from a technical
level of what kind of stuff gets you pwned you know and and and going after that like these cve reversing
um you know sprees that you guys have gone on and i and i loved that piece as well about you breaking
it up into reactive and proactive i think that's really really um awesome and i imagine on the proactive
side you know what what you're doing for that is is you're looking you know you're looking at all of your
your customers you alluded to this before but you're looking at all your customers technology
stacks and i mean do you just pick the one with the you know greatest number or are you looking
for specific things like okay this is java or this is dot net so i know i can hook up a debugger to it
and have a better chance of finding a vault we'll be ready to talk in anything that has enough exposure
for our customers but like for example we looked at cpanel um and that's really yeah that was crazy and
that's like crazy and written in pearl and like all these c binaries and stuff is honestly a mess like
as a security researcher you go into that project and you're like i really don't like working with
this project but but ultimately we'll do anything but but um the proactive side just to note on that
while we look at our customers technologies we're also not afraid to look at technologies that our
customers may not be running now but we might see it on a prospective customer or we might see it on the
attack surface in the future um and this this is often just popular software so if there's any
really popular enterprise software that's usually a good enough target for us that's that's awesome
man so so i guess that's that's for you guys you guys have a great and we can sort of apply these
principles to bug bounty as well you know we can look at the programs we're in we can fingerprint
the technologies and we can do the same thing um but specifically from the cve you know reversing
perspective can you speak to how that could help a bug bounty hunter and what kind of skills they would
develop as well as you know what kind of results they might see if they invest more time into um zero
day research or more specifically cve reversing and and just to tag on to that a little bit can you
also maybe talk about the amount of time it takes and sort of what the input versus output looks like
on these types of things yeah i would say that um most cve reversing work doesn't usually lead to
an immense amount of bounties if there's a lot of patching going on but sure for example if you were
to take if you were to take the metabase research for example um then i think you could potentially get
a few bounties out of that um i when it comes to inputs and outputs i mean it really just depends on
every project every project can be you know like for example for citrix there was no information that
they provided in their advisory that would even hint to us where this may be located it wasn't until
we had other people in the industry publish more things like bishop fox that we saw okay there's some
more information here we can work with this and find potentially what what they're referring to and
and there's always the problem of silent patches which is probably the most frustrating part of this
whole cve reversing game um where they'll release an advisory for an rc that's critical but they'll patch
like five other things in that same release that they don't talk about so i mean there's a lot of
there's a lot of variability when it comes to whether or not we'll find what we're looking for
in the cv reversing project certainly it's much easier on java based and dotnet projects when it comes to
binary based projects that's where it gets really difficult because you're right suddenly now you're
you're diffing the bins and there's like just so much you know so much to go through that's very
esoteric and very difficult to understand at a glance so it's easy to miss things in binary projects but
there's this intersection right with with web and binary when it comes to appliances like you know
vpns and firewalls and things like that and we have to spend more time on this sort of work because
um ultimately these products are exposed on the internet and can lead to a show on their network so
by nature yeah yeah from a bug bounty perspective i think the most profitable
thing to do is find zero days and report them to programs but there is a lot of controversy around
that as you guys have no yeah let's let's uh let's start that conversation yeah yeah yeah yeah um i i
i mean i i personally i personally think there's a lot of value almost like what asset note does right
uh but from the bounty perspective of getting your hands on a a vulnerability with advanced notice
right because um you know the patch cycles especially for some of these bigger companies
um they're going to be a little bit longer and and um it's hard to track down all your assets as
as you know as the asset list grows and grows and grows um and so you know by nature if you get a
couple you know months head start on on oh this this phone is going to be released and you know just a heads up you're vulnerable
uh i think that adds a lot of value and i think that's something that companies should pay for
whether it should be you know their full max crit or whether it should be you know some bonus or some
lower amount um that's you know to be determined i guess by the by the company but uh that's my
position on it do you guys what do you guys think i can't hear what joel thinks i mean yeah yeah let's
get joel okay so from a from a company perspective yeah um it's a it's a it's definitely a tricky
situation right like i i see both sides a lot better than i think some other people in the industry do
mainly because i'm both a bug bounty hunter and like a app app sec engineer yeah so from like the
company perspective it's very tricky when you're using a vendor product and you get that reported as a
vulnerability because the reality is that all you can do is wait for the vendor to fix it especially
if it's a zero day so there's no actual i mean you can like turn it off or you know there are like
certain preventative measures you can do but you can't actually fix it until the company fixes it and
all that you would be kind of expected to do is tell the company hey we got this zero day do you know
about this and if the company says no we don't know about that then it's like you're in a weird
spot where you've kind of ruined the researchers spoils and also alerted the company and now the
company's like hey why don't we know about this um and it but like if you don't report it then like
you're kind of like missing your ethical boundaries so it's very very tricky from a researcher perspective
i think you should just report it to the company and then go ham like that kind of sets your ethical
liability a little bit lower because you've told the company now it's up to the company to fix it if
they fix it really fast and they tell their customers and the customers update it really fast
then good job but you've you know notified and now it's kind of fair game for you at least i think
and then whatever happens happens right if if companies start telling the the vendor that their
product is vulnerable and they've been receiving this zero day then the that's kind of on the vendor
now because the vendor hasn't fixed it fast enough or now the customer is hearing about it so i think it all
kind of goes back on the vendor but as a researcher the main thing that i would want to do is make
sure that i've at least told the company and then spray and pray you know yeah for sure i i i want to
hear i've got so many things i want to say about that joel but i want to hear shoves i want to hear
shoves his opinion first yeah joel i agree with you you reported to the company first and then you
reported to the bug bounty programs but man like in the last few weeks i've even had a situation where
you know it's been really gut-wrenching because i had this pre-auth rc reported it to the vendor
then reported it to a handful of bug bounty programs and um the mistake that uh you know that that that
was made was i didn't tell this vendor that i had reported it to these bug bounty programs specifically
and as a result they they wrote this like email to me where it was like you know gut-wrenching and they
were like you know asset note became the best people we knew to just those guys and i was like
ah shit like i didn't really mean for that relationship with the vendor but but this is
the game like this is this is the zero day zero day game and at the end of the day what what i find
surprising is i i mean their perspective on this they're welcome to have their perspective but the
vulnerability in question if i went to an exploit broker i think i could have sold it for 50 to 100
thousand dollars probably for that that vulnerability now in this case it's really really surprising
because in the bug bounties i must have made like two or four grand that's like a very small amount
of money to be making from this at the end of the day we reported the zero day to the vendor for no cost
and this was zero day research that we did that definitely cost us money so it was our vulnerability
that cost us money to find and we report it to the vendor for free and then we report it to bug
bounty programs after we've reported it to the vendor at that point i'm really struggling to
understand where like you know where we've gone so wrong in this equation when ultimately we've we've
just tried to report it to programs that have this issue on their attack surface i think there are a
few nuances also just quickly on on what joel has mentioned about this is where like you should try
your best not to report zero days and cloud products like sas products onto other companies because
there's really no resolution at all that a company can do like you talked about the preventative
measures that's possible you can add a waft rule you can shut it down you can segregate the network
things like that when it's like a an xss on a that's a zero day in there's like very little that
a customer can do to prevent that from being exploited on their their attack surface so yeah that's where
it gets tricky so so it's really funny that hold on it's really funny that you say that because i
can think of one or two instances actually more than that where a researcher has reported something
and they say hey we've been doing a lot of research and we have the zero day in cloud product here's a
giant link that just like pops an xss or something and you're like okay now what like what do i do
oh man yeah so i mean like on one hand i feel that and i and i understand what you're coming from as
well you know joel with like okay there's not really a lot the company can do but wouldn't you still want
to know like like you know that that's where i kind of say like when people put in their in their
policy that they don't want zero day reports i'm like that's really silly you know it may be to find
something that's like all right we'll pay a medium for or maybe we'll you know decrease the severity by one
so if it's a crit you know we'll drop it to a you know a medium or you know but something like that
but even in even in cloud services you know with with the way that same site cookies are working
nowadays if you if you are able to compromise a domain uh you know subdomain within a company's you
know domain then you are able to do so many more different attacks than you would be able to do before
you know it's a really it's a it's a real problem um and so that's kind of why i'm an advocate for
doing something like yes we'll take the zero day reports but we're gonna maybe lower the bounty
maybe not lower the bounty depending on the impact and if we do have to pull it offline if it's an rce
on a vpn appliance right you better pull that off line and just tell your employees to to get you know
a different way into the company for that time being because you know if you get popped there that's
very very high value and we all know anybody who's ever conducted an external pen test knows
you know as soon as you get in and you get to the or external to internal pen test as soon as you get
in that's it you know like there's it's almost never segmented in such a way that you cannot just
get literal keys to the kingdom once you get in inside so i don't know that's my thought on it
in this next clip from episode 30 we're talking with shubs about advice he has for people building
out their recon flow enjoy for the hunter that is building a a reconnaissance setup now um you know
you having gone through all of the you know many many problems of of you know that you faced building
asset node what what kind of advice do you have to to the bug bounty hunter that wants to build a
continuous reconnaissance platform for their own use just to be clear yeah well i think like justin i
remember you came to me um a couple years ago and you said to me hey man i'm seeing all these people
move to golang like do i need to move to golang as well does this is this the right option to make
i remember telling you like yeah and it was just like because i remember at that point i was maybe
two three years into the asset note um adventure and we had migrated everything to golang from the very
beginning so i had experience working in your stack that you're familiar with which is just like basic
python yeah you know everything's pretty straightforward you can understand it without too much
complexity whereas our golang stack for our enterprise customers which can get quite complex with the
number of microservices and things going on i remember saying to you like choose whatever you're
most comfortable with and what you can iterate in quickly on it doesn't matter if it's golang or
python or whatever it could be visual basic like eric does right it doesn't really matter what language
it is but but i remember you were like really happy with that because you thought that you had to move
to a different language you thought that you were put into this position where the industry is moving
and the industry is changing languages everything everything in golang for various reasons so i have
to do it too and to be frank i was the one in that position when i started asino and i decided to move to
golang there are many benefits that we got out of that but i'm sure if we worked hard enough we could
get something working in python as well um it's it's not really the the distinction of how good the
product is going to be and i see i see this trap a lot with you know people will rewrite things in
a new language like they'll say oh there's xyz tool in this language i'm going to write it in rust now
because rust is so hot right now and everything's amazing in rust but the outcomes are usually the
same like usually the outcomes are very similar all the same sometimes there's speed differences
acceptable i understand but at the end of the day are you going to learn a whole new language to get that
bit of speed difference or are you going to build your systems in a language you're comfortable with
that you can iterate quickly on so that's definitely one of the advices that i would give um the other
one would be like really think about your data sources as much as i would like to say that you know
our reconnaissance techniques and and all of that are a huge contributor there's also a huge element
where the data that we have access to is just overpowered compared to other other people's data sources so
that that sort of stuff if you start looking at things like passive dns if you start investigating
these things and start understanding where you can get these data sources what these data sources look
like how much you're willing to pay for them you're suddenly putting yourself at an immense advantage
compared to almost every other bug bounty hunter out there and um i think one last thing is um just have
an environment where you can quickly iterate code on when i was first building asset node i did all of my
programming in the equivalent of github code build so back then there was something called cloud nine
and i used that to do all of my iteration it was so quick like i was building so so quickly today you've
got things like code spaces i think sorry in in github that's an equivalent of what i was using back then
when i was building the very first iterations of asset node wow dude that was just a treasure trove of
of advice there thank you so much for sharing that and i i remember that conversation very clearly
and i just i left that conversation like you said ecstatic you know with the results of what you said
and it served me well for the rest of the time you know that i was in the recon game like being able to
quickly develop code in python it was it was invaluable and i think also one of the great things that
that just came out of that conversation for me was appreciation for that right because like if i had gone
on down the other route and i and i had you know written all this going code i might oh man i used
to remember when i used to be able to write code you know off the top of my head without even thinking
about it in python that's that's great but you know and then i would have earned the ability to like
you know um yeah appreciate python but without having to go to that through that difficulty and that
route you made me aware every time i wrote python code quickly how much of a blessing that is and how much
of a you know of a win that was so thank you so much for your advice man that that really that really made a big
difference in my recon game in this last clip from episode 30 shoves dropped some hot hot spicy hacker
advice on how to hack iis servers he's the master on this you're not going to want to skip this one
so i i did have a couple more things that i wanted to ask um specifically regarding iis um which is your
bread and butter it seems right you've done a lot of you've done some videos on iis stuff which we'll link
in the description and um what can you tell us about hacking iis servers what do you have for the
people yeah for sure i think i think the second you see an iis server you should thank god because
it's the easiest thing to hack out of all the other web servers that are out there you should be grateful
you should be grateful that you've come across the presence of an iis server you see that blue page
that comes up when you hit an iis server that that should be your your point in time where you think
i'm gonna find criticals on this oh my gosh i'd love that because because 90 of the time like like
like guys if you think about every other web server technology which other web server technology lets
you guess partial files and folder names there's nothing out there like that like yeah that's just
ridiculous and this vulnerability this issue has existed for like 10 years plus like it's been around
for so long and it still works on the latest version of iis like this is not even something that
they're thinking about seriously fixing in future versions so far that i've seen so there's that
right you've got the ability to see partial file names and folders with enough reconnaissance you can
figure out the rest of those file names and folders by doing some fuzzing so on so forth then there's all
this other stuff that happens with dot net and specifically with iis and dot net where you are able to
get a shell if you get local file disclosure now if you if you if you get local file disclosure and you
read a web.config file it has the machine key the validation key you're able to escalate that from
just that to to command execution again the the only solution for this is you start storing these
values in the in the in the windows registry instead of the web.config file 90 of the time companies are
storing it in the web.config file and this is something that you know often leads to command
execution once you get local file disclosure then there's the other aspect of this where when you when
you audit dot net um products you've got to deal with this whole idea of windows shares and windows
domains so let's say you find an ssrf that ssrf on our is server on a dot net product is much more than
just reaching a web server nine times out of ten if they're using path.join then in path.join you can
just do backslash backslash uh and and put in like a windows share backslash c dollar sign backslash and
suddenly because of the windows apis that are being used for these network requests windows
willingly shares the ntlm net ntlm hash with your server so you run responder on your server and
suddenly you've escalated an ssrf to a critical much more critical than just being http requests so
there's stuff like that then there's like you know i guess there's also this there's also this amazing
thing with dot net and ias where there's like a thousand different ways to drop a shell like when
you drop shells in ias and dot net you can drop shells with web.configs with ascx files with as hx
files with aspx files you can drop shells in so many different ways it's it's beautiful and it's really
great to be able to to to hack on on on on dot net is servers and one last thing that i love one last
thing is if you're exploiting an xxe in in an in a dot net application there is an xxc payload that is
universal for windows that uses a dtd file that's within the windows file system that's yeah always
present in the windows file system that will nine times out of ten that you leak file contents when
you probably shouldn't be able to these are all the different things that's that's sick and i i want that
payload we're i'm gonna make a note right now get get the xsc c payload from shubs uh because that that
seems really helpful i've seen some stuff floating around but it'd be nice to have it here you know
and link it down in the description for the people that are interested dude that that was such a treasure
trove of of knowledge i i feel like dude i'm so lucky to be able to have you on here because i just like
throw a little like you know question out there and then there's just like boom gold boom gold boom gold
and we were actually just talking about the um you know the the share paths last week and how crazy
it is that you get those ntlm hashes um and and that you can interact with shares you know when you
have ssrf as well um so that's that's really cool really cool stuff um and definitely for those of you
that haven't hacked on ias stuff check out short uh check out short scan um bit quirks uh you know
tilde enumeration tool and then also read all the write-ups that will link below uh for shubs on ias
related stuff because um like you said man i get excited when i see that that blue page and i think
most other hackers uh should as well um that's that's all i had on the list for today um a shubs
do you have anything else you want to you want to share anything you want to talk about where can we
find you on on socials as well uh just two last things i want to share and then we can wrap it up
great one of them is when you see the blue page on ias do not skip it please yes there's something
there like there's there's no reason they've just spun up an ias server for no reason like like they
wouldn't just do that most companies have something there there is something there please keep keep
looking keep finding it whatever there's something there and the second thing is um just one other
lesser known technique in ias is virtual directory um virtual like uh path traversal to traverse into
different virtual servers via virtual directories so in ias you can set up directories that are pointing
to different servers and if you use path traversal within those directories you can see the web root of
different servers this is something that i've found um quite common in ias deployments that are complex
so they'll have slash sso pointing to 10.1.1.1 and but it's pointing to 10.1.1.1 slash sso so you can go
slash sso dot dot percentage 2f and then that will route you to 10.1.1.1 to the dock route ah okay so
it's your path traversing on the back end server in the reverse that's right okay that's right yeah this
is similar to sam curry that's an ias behavior specifically yes this is an ias behavior specifically
this is very similar to sam curry's secondary context right work right um but but but then this
this can lead to a lot of crazy vulnerabilities because in many cases they don't expect you to
be able to access the dock route of 10.1.1.1 and you can just brute force and find whatever you want and
and and go from there so that's the last tip that i i don't think is publicly talked about that much so
just want to give that to your audience as well already the next episode we have up on the docket
is episode 37 tokyo hacking an interview with lupin this is a great clip where we're talking about js
weasel and cursor two awesome smart javascript analysis plugins for vs code and we also cover how
to take that js data and build great word lists for things like carry avoidance or rest api hacking enjoy
you mentioned a a when we were walking down the street to the to the freaking uh shrine earlier
today to meet up with friends um you know you mentioned that there was this vs code uh plugin
that that you've been using um and i imagine it actually would work well in conjunction with js weasel
exactly yeah yeah could you talk a little bit about that because that was a really interesting product
yeah so i saw uh the tweet of corbin that basically used js weasel uh with cursor and cursor is like a
wrapper around vs code since vs code is mostly open source and basically they are embedding uh gpt4
inside the vs code and you can directly ask questions about your code base what's really interesting is
that you can pay um the subscription but you can also directly natively use your gpt4 api key so you
directly pay to open ai and no need to go through their servers okay and um it's so amazing like uh
right now i i'm using it to do uh jasky analysis on uh google that they use like a lot of rpc weird
calls like it's horrible proprietary protocol yeah and basically i'm going like okay that's the edge
point of the request right so what are the parameters because they are like so embedded in one function to
another function to another function and basically i just asking the ai um tell me which other function
you want context to so i can provide it to you and we can reconstruct the request and i did that like
maybe five six times and at one point i just got the request that i needed to send wow and like the
protobuf request and i was like oh that's amazing and it just built it automatically yeah wow and so i
used js weasel to detect uh which like like all the endpoints you did some automation also to get the
ideas right and then you just ask cursor okay explain to me this code and this is the job like
instead of having like six to seven hours of code review you do it like maybe in two hours it's so
great i love it wow it's really interesting like i think this is something before ai or like gpt was
really yeah more you know before it was as as flushed out as it is this would be something that you
might have like code ql or maybe some more of a technical tool be doing but this the approach is
basically just feeding it into ai and saying hey what do i need to know about this it's so much more
powerful because it can do everything just like in an instant where it just analyzes this huge chunk
of data and is able to just parse it and tell you oh yeah here's what you need to know i'm i'm a little
i'm a little confused about how that works though because i feel like the code base would extend past
the context window any any i do do either of you guys know how that works or is it with gpt for
like 8k or something i don't know um so uh basically when i use it i select the lines of
code i wanted to to interpret uh but they natively use a way to uh compress the file and basically
they have like some kind of if i understood correctly a search engine on the client side
the that depending on the question will go look for the code before and then giving the context to
open ai so you do not have to give everything i see a bit like being search is doing like the
search engine uh does the first request and then give the data back to open ai and open ai will
uh put context i see i see yeah that's really interesting because like what you meant we were
talking earlier about like tokens and and sort of how like ai looks at input as tokens and it splits it
up into different segments that it can understand better and sort of looks at those pieces
individually and then we'll build like the context together and i think that's like what you said
like it the way that it parses that is kind of counterintuitive because you might think like oh
you know i can't feed a giant filing but you can because it it can do some more processing magic on
it than yeah before um i mean like llm are trained on so many data points that actually they can complete
it context uh so if you say this function passes something they can guess uh it's not like the the
more accurate way to do it but i think the cursor team did a great job about knowing what to feed to
the ai and knowing like what they already know so you you can like compress as much as possible the
tokens to not you know pay the 8k subscription right right right um yeah and i think combining those
two tools together js weasel and and um was it cursor cursor okay like mouse cursor yeah okay gotcha
gotcha um yeah combining those two tools together is a really powerful combo so shout out to corbin for
for that one um uh yeah i'm i'm definitely i'm definitely interested to see where all that goes and
js weasel uh i think we'll probably cover in a little bit more detail on a different episode
um but i i booted it up for the first time during this live hacking event and i've been using it and
uh it's really cool to see it do automatically what we talked about you know breaking out those
those um uh file web packed js files and having it you know drop all of the things there um but i'm
wondering i don't know if you've used it joel but for for you lupin um i'm wondering uh how you've been
using the tool because for me i've been having a little bit of a difficulty with and i talked to charlie
about this and i think he's fixing it but um i've been having a little bit of difficulty with
identifying the portions of the js code that i really want to analyze because there's not a
search function presently yeah um and so i mean do you do you have that same struggle have you worked
around it what how are you using the tool currently yeah um the the tool misses like a search uh function
that's definitely something uh that needs to be implemented um the way i use it is more about like
um knowing the attack surface and the constructing uh word list out of it so uh basically i had um
this graphql uh api uh that was um behind authentication and so it was just for admins right
but you could with a low privilege user just because uh you know cookies are white you could make
uh simple request to it but without authorization of course and um the introspection wasn't turned on
okay so how do you know which queries do you do you go to the js files right and what i did with jess
weasel that was awesome it listed all the queries i just copied all the queries and uh generated world
list that i gave to clairvoyance right and basically uh clairvoyance would try to brute force
the the schema the graphial schema and give it back to you and so then i fit the 70 mo
like it was a big schema uh to graphial viager and i had like everything every call that it was being
made because they like in when there is a graph here everything is always documented in the front end
i don't know why there is some libraries that even have introspection inside the js like if it's not
turned out go check the js and you can copy the introspection and paste it just because they
forgot to turn a flag i've never seen that yeah i've seen like a lot of times and it's so interesting
um so so it's so funny you mention that because i literally did the exact same thing i i except i
didn't use js weasel for it i used my own parsing script to you know uh expand the webpack files yeah
and then i did exactly that i i took a regex i pulled every string that was compliant with uh
graphql um you know naming standards essentially for for queries and for um for field names and that
sort of thing i put it all in a word list and i fed it to clairvoyance um and for those of you that
are listening that aren't familiar we'll link it down below but clairvoyance is a is a um is a tool
that uh i guess sort of plays on the problem with graphql where they will recommend you yeah uh fields if
you have the improperly uh defined fields so uh you know let's say you there's a field called store
and you know sometimes it's even like like pretty pretty far like you might even get away with like
sport and it may be did you mean store yeah and they'll tell you it really depends on the back end
so depending on the language uh you can set up uh the amount of token that needs to to be uh the same
so really interesting yeah so sometimes it's like two tokens apart so two letters sometimes
have this three four uh and they can set up that on the back end side and depending on the framework
they will have a different kind of uh far way or not you know yeah well i mean it's really
interesting that you mentioned that that that strategy with graphql because i was i was gonna
say the same thing about not even just graphql but same thing with api requests like if yes if
you're pulling apart those webpack uh files and the lazy loaded files not only will you see the end
points but you also see how they're being used where is that data coming from and one of the really
powerful things about having all of that just right in front of you in javascript it's just like
android apps where you know you can decompile it you can see how everything is working like right in
front of you you can do the same thing with the javascript all you have to do is pull it apart you
can see oh it's making a post request and it builds the body with these fields that are named this
and that data comes from here it's a parameter and that's fed in through here and you can track it all
and you can see sort of how that data flows through the application to get to that request and you
can piece it together without ever having used the application at all you can do it completely from
static analysis yeah yeah all righty next up is episode 45 the og bug bounty king franz rosen what
an episode that was in the segment that we chose we're talking about a lot of good stuff but primarily
we're talking about app cache service workers cookie stuffing and post message specifically i remember
having an excellent conversation with franz surrounding chaining crlf injections with service workers
uh which resulted in some sort of novel ideas i haven't heard before so hope you guys enjoy it
bringing us back on track to the to the hacking stuff i did want to talk about one of my favorite
um talks that you've ever done which just essentially looked like prophecy to me looking back in in
in the past which is your attacking modern web technologies talk that you did in 2018 um
um uh almost exactly five years ago yeah um and attacking modern web technologies there were so
many awesome pieces to this there was um app caches and service workers uh you know there was post message
stuff there was i mean yeah the the policies the s3 policies all sorts of stuff all over the place so
um once again mandatory mandatory reading for anybody who's listening um the crazy thing about to me about
this talk is like this is still the stuff that we're talking about today like yeah and this was five
years ago right yes it's still applicable yeah yeah i find bugs like like sometimes i need to go back
to those slides because i find bugs for those things exactly they have extremely long lifespan those blog
posts yeah i surprised myself that it's like still working and this is something that's really i think
a key listen and also help helps for your for your brand as well franz is that franz was was talking
about this stuff not not only doing this stuff but talking about it publicly in 2018 five years ago
and i i we talked about post message still being an underserved technology even to this day so keep an
eye on anything franz releases because it it will very likely be applicable for the future um uh so talk
to me a little bit about uh app cache and and service worker stuff and then um in conjunction with
that the beauty of the synergies between cookie stuffing and and these technologies yeah so i think
the the the interesting part with the app cache uh that that happened there there were there were many
many fun things with it but my aspect of it was that i had a really old dropbox account and the old
dropbox account were like grandfathered into a place where you could actually host websites on on
dropbox user content.com and you and if you created a new dropbox account back then you couldn't really
run your own like you couldn't render html pages and stuff but if you had a legacy dropbox account you
could but it was very limited into what you could actually trigger with it or like get it to to render
um and i came to the conclusion that like what can i do with an xss or running an xss on on dropbox user
content and i i remember i was talking with matthias then and like what can we do like can we do something
and we came to the conclusion like okay cookie stuffing we can do so you can make it like unable
to actually load because you're filling up the cookie jar so much so when you're making a request
later on it will fail so so question here so essentially what was happening is you were able to
host your uh you know attacker controlled content on a domain with with other attack you know victim
content on on that same domain right yeah exactly what happened was you got like a user directory on
dropbox user content that you could host data on uh and then you could uh i think it was that
oh i can see it now and i'll reference it it's slide 15 for any of those of you that are following along
here um you know he's got dl dropbox user content.com slash you and then the user id and then wherever you
would update stuff and you got the xss not by uploading an html file but by using svg yeah well i think it was an
xml xml xml you're right you're right yes xml yeah so that was the thing uh everything else was
like you know getting downloaded and position attachment uh but that was the way but but if
you had a new dropbox account you would never get the url to to uh you dropbox user user content it was
only the legacy dropbox account that's really that feature enabled um so that was the you know the the
weird part first with with having that so we knew that we could do cookie stuffing and what would
happen then if if somebody else sent the link that would like 404 and or the four of four of five or
something i i or five five zero something four eleven uh i think yeah actually yeah yeah so so that
concept of of um cookie stuffing i learned that from from you and from file descriptor and and so i think
it was my descriptor that that i learned it from it was from i was gonna ask where did you get that
knowledge and of course it goes back to another legend file descriptor yeah file descriptor man and
and the funny thing with this bug was that i think matthias was the one meant we're coming back to file
descriptor so yeah he mentioned appcache and i started reading up on what appcache was doing and matthias as
well and we started like playing with that and realized that we could you know host reference a
manifest in in the xml file that manifest would then be loaded and that manifest could be like a
regular text or whatever sure and that text could contain and say that if if you're unable to reach
this website you should have a fallback your fallback page of this and that sure because the whole appcache
thing was based on you running an app and you're going offline with your cell phone so you need to if you
reload the page you can still visit this is crazy and absolutely crazy and what happened was that we
realized that in our user path we could put an html file or an xml file and we could say that this is
the one that should be loaded if you can't reach the website and then we realized okay does the cookie
stuffing result in this thing and it turns out that yes so we cookie stuffed and made sure that if you
clicked on any other link we would just steal the url and then steal the the page of that signed url
that's amazing but the weird part of us that when we did this blog post i don't know exactly date wise
so our bug to dropbox was here and then here yeah and then file descriptor comes out with a talk uh
explaining this bug and we were like but we what we what so that that was when we wanted we got the
dropbox uh bug published so we could show that we also figured this out that's crazy uh and and so so
he actually did a talk on i think on the oas talk or something else but and so we like we came to the
same kind of conclusion uh which was great so i wanted to like highlight that that like sometimes
people can like figure out the same kind of things at the same time uh and as you mentioned uh like
there's like the new thing i i think i mentioned it as well like service workers was uh was uh like a
replacement for app cache but back then i think it was like very hard to like get the uh service
worker to work because yeah you needed to have like a specific header on the service worker file
to allow it to run as a service worker and there were a lot of like if this and that's that that had to
work uh to make it actually yeah it seems like there's there's definitely been some change in that
area now and so um you know i've definitely seen service workers used in in lots of different different
contexts i believe you and i i always have to you know go back and look at it but i'm not 100 sure but
i i i'm 99 sure that service workers can be installed without a header now at the header that if you do
supply an http response header what that will allow you to do is reassign the uh the root system the
the the um authority for that service worker so if you you know even though you're installing the
service worker at like slash js slash sj.js or whatever or sw.js um then then you know you normally
just have authority for the slash js directory but if you're able to serve that service worker allowed i
think header um then you can get uh and say hey give it permission to slash then you can now affect all
the resources wrong everywhere um and it's it's such an interesting technology
especially when you pair it with something like uh subdomain takeover or yeah or um you know
uh file upload because you can gain sort of sort of a persistence in the browser as well um yeah using
service workers and and um you know that that we've seen this also with truffle security released a tool
called of course i'm not sure if you've seen it franz but it's it's um it uses a service worker in the
background to uh gain more time to be able to attack different um websites that have vulnerable course
configurations even if you just visit the page for just an instant you know so there's so many um
i think applicable you know exploitation scenarios for service workers um that that we we got to keep
our eye on because they have tremendous impact yeah no and i agree but like i i guess the core concept
of course is that you need to have an xss to begin with yes and and then you probably need to have
arguments on why that xss wasn't important in the beginning and i guess like storage like a bucket
storage is a it's a it's a good argument on like an xss there doesn't do anything but if you have
persistence you can like show and i think that was what the the the bug showed was like it's a sandbox
domain it doesn't have any impact but you have persistence and and and that's the way to like
gain access to other urls and stuff i just thought about something franz you know one of the things
we're going to talk about a little bit later assuming we don't have to cut for time is this middleware
misconfigurations yeah that you you talked about so what if we change that right like we we change the
middleware misconfiguration um and and so now we we can use that to hit a different bucket on the so just
to be i'm going to give the tldr of the of the middleware misconfiguration thing if you if you
essentially with some nginx configurations if you hit it if you put a bunch of escape characters you
know um new lines and stuff like that in the url and they have some specific proxy pass rules
um then you will be able to re rewrite the rest of the request and hit other s3 buckets or other
backend entities and host your own content exactly so what if we we changed that with service workers right
um where you could then hit your own s3 bucket and an issue but i'm wondering i mean you still have
stored stored xss i guess like somebody needs to visit your url still and and that one would still
make you host whatever content you want on that website so but the the thing you're getting is the
pres the the persistent thing right you can actually make it load but they still need to visit it once can
you can you can you i'm wondering though can you set response headers in s3 yeah it depends if it's s3
website you can some of them uh but i mean you could also if it's s3 website you can still redirect it to
whenever like and depending on like the csp for example you can still redirect it elsewhere i don't
know if that helps you though no no because what i'm thinking is like wouldn't it be cool if we could
insert some some new line characters overwrite the the back end bucket right have the bucket serve a a
service worker and then insert the service worker header to slash so now so we we gain you know that
service worker authority um and get xss stored xss on every single page that the user visits within
the browser i think that can be really i mean s3 website would allow you to do this if it's if the
s3 website uh is if it's proxying you to s3 website and you can inject something to modify what bucket
it's going to serve as a website you can inject whatever happens it depends on the host because i
wonder i wonder if if we are hitting so let's say they're sending a request to you know whatever dot s3
on amazon aws.com and then we overwrite the host header on that i wonder if it uses that same load
balancer origin ip for you to insert a header to hit s3 websites like if you if you put in it doesn't
okay no uh s3 website is also quirky because it only responds on http and not https oh what uh i have no
idea why i think it has something to do with like you're supposed to put it behind something else kind
of cloud front or whatever but so they they don't have the same load balancer and you can't really
get to s3 website from s3 as far as i know it weird yeah that's that's definitely it's very isolated it's
like a totally it's like an overlay over s3 it's like s3 website is like its own thing that renders
whatever you want basically yeah we'll definitely have to research that a little bit more the the other
area that i was thinking that this could be interesting is with crlf injection uh and into
the response headers right if you can do response splitting assign the service worker allowed header
then you can make a service worker out of the response splitting yeah sure that would be pretty
you need something to load it i mean you could probably make two crlf one crlf to load a fake document
and one crlf that loads a fake service worker with the header to install it absolutely that should work
yeah sure that's that's that's some good that's some good right there um that's fun then you get
persistence yeah huh i'm just interesting i'm thinking about all the possibilities i can see the
gears turning as soon as he hangs up he's gonna he's got three programs he's gonna go look at then you
you then you and then you can probably you know escalate it to you know steal access tokens and
stuff and yeah i mean you can probably do things with that and it makes it a lot more it makes it i
mean it's a little bit interesting right because technically what that could result in then is we
could get plain we could leak the user's plain text password without user interaction right because i like
like you said what what are we actually what do we actually gain from this because at that point if
we have stored xss right then we can just open up whatever pages we want in an iframe and then do
whatever we want right and do whatever yeah but but one of the things that we can't do is is without
more entry user interaction is leak the user's plain text password assuming they don't have any crazy
thing yeah but but due to the persistence you can uh you can get them to yeah sure which which really
escalates pretty much any and then i guess it's a reflected more than uh stored but you turn it into
more of a stored client-side store yeah yeah a client-side stored xss client-side store that's
that's really interesting and then and then this this is a really good um ato mechanism because some
especially if you then proceed to cookie bomb like a a specific path that that issues you know an auth
token or something like that it forces the user to to clear their cookies and re-auth the next time
that they go into the application and at that point if you've got the service worker you can hijack the
the plain text password yeah we get that this is some good i didn't get you on this podcast more often
this is great no no this is really good okay so um wow as much as i would like to sit there and just
uh think on that for the next little while let's let's try to keep rolling um it's probably a sin
but i'm going to skip this whole uh section on um s3 policies and cloud policy uploads which is a
really awesome part of of the attacking modern web technologies uh talk and i'm going to jump to
something that we've talked a little bit more about on the podcast uh often which is um the the post
message stuff um yeah so uh how did you because i once again you're one of the one of the first
people that i i you know sort of introduced me to post message stuff yeah where where did you how did
you come up with this and then what what was it like you know sort of seeing this did somebody else's
research spur this thought in you or was it just how does this work no sort of that's that's a really
good do you remember i guess the first no i don't i actually don't 100 remember yeah where i think i
think like this i think there were examples of vulnerable cases already sure like i wasn't the one
showing that you can exploit it uh but i started to so i think i did a lot of focus back then on i think
it was dropbox sure maybe yeah and i think it was so it was also like payment providers there was something
because payment providers tend to do a lot of and you had to talk yourself about it yeah yeah and and
what happened was that there was a as a as a huge amount of payment providers that started moving over
to post message and you always had a really hard part finding all the post message listeners so as i did
back then i was discussing with matthias like how how do we figure these things out and and we came to
the conclusion that like okay probably an extension and then i sat down and wrote a bunch of like
you know inside iframes deep you know post message that that get listeners that get triggers by actions and
and a lot of different i think it's still in the repository there's like an example dot html with a bunch of
listeners and and just to like try to figure out what we can do about it and i i made my first uh
version of the of the extension and like okay this will be usable like oh just the number even though
you have like five iframes deep a listener the number counter on the post message listener chrome
extension would still you know increase versus looking at the the source uh events global events and
you only see the iframe you're currently selected yeah i was like this is a terrible functionality
uh so i made my first version of this and i i talked with the google team because i told them
like why can't you just like i don't want to start building an extension like can't you just fix so you
can see all the listeners in all iframes yeah and they're like no this is how it's supposed to be and
blah blah blah and it's terrible and it's something that i talked about in my talk as well but like
yeah you got to do your do in in you still even have to do your due diligence to go and show where
all of the you know to to go assess all of the listeners because something may not be utilizing that
listener right so in that case it won't show up in post message tracker so you've still got to go
through and do it one of the you know it's my fault is as well because i haven't contributed to that
nice private repo you put me on for for post message tracker but i think it would be really cool to to
add a a line that that shows every time a post message tracker is registered and where it's
registered so you so you you know just like you get a request where you know you get a log in your
console when it gets sent through um when a post message is sent through you can also get a log when
one is registered so you can know okay well the you know my uh child windows third iframe has
registered a launched uh yeah yeah a listener that that could be really cool because that attack surface
is all over the place like you mentioned absolutely and and i would say the most common ones i found
nowadays are the ones not initiated from from start but by action yeah so they they just because you so i
have an example in one talk i did on in amsterdam for like a live hacking event basically what happened
was that when you clicked on upload document there was a listener started at that action and then you
could do whatever you could basically read whatever document you uploaded you could read it from the
sandbox uh but but so there's a bunch of those like action-based listeners that gets triggered by things
and what i've seen lately like lately also i think one of the biggest tricks that up my sleeve with the postman
seditioner was the unpacking of the wrappers yeah so basically everything is wrapped through new new relic or
roll bar or there's a bunch of those but and jquery also has its own wrapper but the way of figuring out how to
bypass the wrapper and then go directly to the function so you can get like the real function that is actually being
triggered that was i think the the golden nugget in in the extension that is that that was really helpful
and what i've seen lately now is like people using message ports which is like an addition to to post
message where you send an initial post message with the port and that port can then be you know you can
shuffle that port between iframes but the one having the port is the one getting the messages yeah dude i'm
so glad you mentioned that because i just found my first you know bug using message ports in a live hacking
event maybe well i won't say exactly when because because that'll give it away but but within the past
year right um and and it was uh it was very interesting and i think one of the things that that was crazy
there is it it sometimes people will just get a port and then they'll just shove data into it without doing you know
origin checks or anything like that too no no no so you know it actually even creates more complexity
and more room for vulnerabilities when you when you're utilizing the message port stuff yeah and
it's fun because you can you can have a message port from one little iframe and if you get hold of that
message port you can take it into a different iframe and then the the the window thinking it sends
sends it to the iframe it's actually sending it cross-domain somewhere else so yeah that message
port can be you can juggle that message port wherever you want which is quite kind of funny
that it's like just a connection it's basically like a a socket that you can that shuffles data it's
i'm also kind of surprised that we haven't seen more post message based tooling out there like maybe
i'm just naive but your post message tracker is pretty much the only extension that i've seen
that that does anything like this so um one thanks for doing that because otherwise you'd have no
introspection i use it i use it every day myself it's my the only proly extension i use myself and
every every day i'm looking at it so it's like i'm it's a good example of like writing something that
would you would use yourself yeah and it's 100 like that like it doesn't go a day without me looking at
i i'd kind of like also to just to highlight you know the importance of understanding browser
mechanics and stuff like that so let's say for example you you you know post message stuff was
just coming out or something like that right and you go to a page and you see a an iframe open up or
not an iframe a pop-up you know open up and it does something and then it you know that change somehow
seems to appear back on the on the original window right yeah and you don't see any http requests so
it's not pushing it out to the server and not coming back right so you're like wait a second how the
heck is this working because if you have a an understanding of browser mechanics you you know
you would need you need some sort of reference to pass it and that sort of thing same origin kind of
works still yeah same origin is fine for that yeah yeah so it's important to understand you know if
it's happening cross origin like that you can't just you know say parent you know or opener dot you
know window you know whatever and just define variables or trigger callbacks in the parent window
if it's cross-origin so you so having a strong understanding of same origin policy having a strong
understanding of of um window references you know those sort of things are essential to be able to
identify these sort of issues um as the technology evolves absolutely so and i think i one one thing
that i i did some talks on it but i think is there will be a lot more bugs on it it's it's client side
race conditions with post message i i think that's i think i was early on with it uh but i think that
there are much more places to investigate that might be similarly vulnerable to it i i i don't have
so i've got a couple client side race conditions um in place um bugs that i found and i'm actually doing
some research on them right now uh which i'll share with you after this after this chat um and maybe we
can collab on it because uh the implications of it are pretty gnarly um but uh it's i need to do what
you did with uh a lot 30 dancing and just like you know work through all the all the pathways yeah
work with all the pathways to it but yeah i mean there's so many things that can be said about that
one piece that is not super relevant to the to the um to the bug that the or to the research that i'm
talking about is the the concept of client-side racial conditions via post message when um one of the
people is using json dot parse so the thing about json dot parse is that it it when you're parsing
that that json data from a string back into a json object that takes computational power to load up all
those objects right so i had a scenario when i was getting a post message at two different windows at
the same time right and i needed to be so this window was relay the first window that would receive
the post message was relaying it to me the attacker but then that first window would respond to the
post message and set some configuration settings right so i had to receive it needed the message
to be first but you also needed to read it faster than that exactly so the first the first window that
received it was using json parts yeah and instead matching i guess exactly i used i used just substring
right to extract this this variable that i needed to send the message and was able to win the race
back to the first window oh that's awesome and and so uh that's a that's a cool little little tip i
love those those things are are beautiful json parse is a little bit um computationally also also i think
like the whole concept of sending uh object like arbitrary objects i know filerscriptor made one of those
using blob yeah uh but there there are a bunch like you can send a regex object yeah and and so there's
a bunch of these like if this is not a string kind of bugs that you can find just because you're sending
a completely different object with post message uh i think it's like file blob regex there's a bunch
of more that you can uh you can send over wow i didn't know that actually i got to look into that and
i know that some some providers have implemented frameworks where like serialization and deserialization
frameworks that just make my life terrible they are crazy i know i know exactly what you mean i've
seen those as well yeah it takes a lot a lot of time but sometimes in those cases i i rather look for
the the sinks first exactly or like like is it even you know i would have time to go down this path yeah
exactly yeah no totally those are tricky for our last interview clip this is with mr fall down the
well himself matthias of leadenbrun carlson uh this is just a spectacular part of the episode where he
talks all about xslt and mxss mutation xss and all the sorts of tooling and interesting intricacies with
care sets and all sorts of really really cool stuff make sure to check this one out char sets
no char sets cares cares char sets probably char sets either way enjoy the episode
so a part of my research for the technical shit section is um going through every tweet you've ever
tweeted and finding all the interesting stuff and uh talk getting ready to talk about that so you put out
this tool uh hack a planet 10. uh it's it's hack the planet in spanish can you say it hack your planet
i don't know man's uh the lords we just update that's great you own that domain the dot se domain and uh
html parse in it this is super awesome so essentially what it does you go to this this thing here you submit
an html document and then it runs dom purify on it it and it puts it through all of these um
different server-side html renderers and shows you the result um so tell me why you did this and can
you well first explain you're looking for mutation xss here apparently why are you looking for mutation
xss and what is mutation xss okay so mutation xss is like if you take a payload and just give it to
the browser knows no alert box will pop essentially but if you put it through some
course first like even one that's inside of the browser itself which is mxs like right in an html
uh setting or like the dom parser and etc and then it will essentially try to fix errors and in the
markup and while inserting those fixes it actually turns it into like success let's say so so if i'm
understanding correctly the browser or the the sort of i guess dom rendering engine whatever it is it could
be a server-side html parser it could be a browser it could be you know some other modif modification
within the browser when you give it some html document that is not spec compliant typically right
you know it it will look at this thing and say okay can't render this because it's not spec compliant
let me see what i can do to fix it and when it does that it will inadvertently cause xss is that right
yeah that's exactly right it's a bug in the i'll fix your bad markup love that thank you for your help
uh browsers and dom renders all around we we love that you we can rely on you for this sort of thing
so so what was the motivation for this tool man what did you why did you build this and what kind
of stuff have you been finding with it well the motivation was it actually had nothing to do with xss
yes but yeah well it was like a it wasn't like a xml bug but i knew they accepted you it was weird
because you could send html to it instead of xml and i was like hmm i wonder what parser they're
using because there were certain tags they wouldn't allow me to use and i needed them to exploit stuff yeah
and i had this idea like i wonder if i can hide the tags from them somehow but when it forwards it
it will actually be unhidden because some other parser where it actually ends up after that
treats it in a different way so i was like okay how surely there's some tool you can just spin up all
of these things and you see like how does each parser parse it sure it's like nope and then standard
moment in all its life oh man someone should build this i'm that someone i guess i'm someone
so that's great man so you you went and you built it you took how many
geez i mean you press parse in here and it just keeps on going so you've got so many
16 parsers a bunch of them wow dude how much of a pain in the butt was that to uh to do i mean the
base problem was uh choosing whether i should implement like a whole website for it or if i
should make a like a hack which i ended up doing like do i need to make have like a web server and
a whole mdc framework just to call this parsing function and see what it does uh but instead do it
build it with apache and cgi actually and then it will just run like see a live version of it
wow very cool man yeah so that's i took the shots about this actually which way to do it in a practical
way because i'm like it's gonna take a long time if i'm i have to build an actual application dude
oh i see you open sourced it too yeah yeah yeah so that's what i did and uh oh it's got a docker
it's got dude i did not see this when i did the research this is this uh each one of them is a
its own docker container no dude and then so okay so you've got it in a docker container and then you
can literally just do echo your your your dom pipe it into docker exec and then give it the name of
the parcel you want and it'll just do it yeah that's dude this is so you can like pass it through
that if you like to or you can use the the beautiful web interface this is really well architected dude
i'm really impressed nice nice work with this do you have any um so did you did you pop the xml thing
or no i did i did and like uh because i managed to uh hide tags with it because it forced the um
it's the middle comments incorrectly ah it didn't recognize dash dash exclamation
greater than as an end of a comment ah but you can also like okay
okay if you if you saw some like only that's like uh i have put in like a combination of those things
that i found for different parses that we like hide the content of the document oh up at the top
there is that no what are you like um on just the home page of obviously that i see if you take for
example just standard uh uh a beautiful suit and html character and and you try to scrape my site and
like take the links you cannot do no way really and it's same with like floppy like a couple of hours but
so yeah that was like the second like interesting challenge i thought of when building that's just like
hmm i wonder if you can hide from from scrapers like what implications can't be the good old regex
though that's true that's true yeah no that's really cool though i love that you built that in that's
like some serious hacker hacker shit right there when you like make your own way you implement this on your
own website just for the kicks yeah so that they can't you know pull your linkedin and your twitter from
i believe in brun.se high value high value links you've got there only for human eyes
uh yeah no no so i did find some stuff and i i have been thinking about implementing like
the same with xml parsers that's something that i that i think could have specific bugs too and like
100 months of research area pick a bunch of different standardized xml parsers see how they
treat that external types around the type of xxc issues and play around with it because there was
someone in the in the legal thinking podcast this but actually i don't think they meant what i thought
they meant but they gave me another day out that like okay maybe there's a person that doesn't require
the doctor declaration to be at the start of the document and ah oh i saw that conversation that
looked interesting but but that would make xxc like a new type of xxc i guess which would be like
external doc type injection so when you when you're injecting into the body of the external document
instead of controlling the whole thing so i actually have a piece of research that i want to say
i don't remember whether i actually put it into the saml episode for for critical thinking but there
is a chrome browser exploit that was a couple weeks ago not the one that that dropped in the critical
thinking research uh xxc one recently um where they were using xslt transforms to do some crazy stuff with the
some crazy stuff with the placement of that entity you know the doc type tag um and so there essentially
it was like it was using the parser to stick it up at the top and on one on the first parser it would
it would not have it at the top and on the next one it would and trigger the xxt um so the other cool
thing you can do with that is the xslt transforms which i am really excited to dive into deep more i hope i
hope some of the listeners go and do this research because i i'm super swamped with stuff right now
but i would love to see any researcher research on xslt maybe i can nerd snipe you on it dude the
transforms are so cool i've did have you have you like learned at all about xslt transforms yeah i found
it's a something bug one and a half week ago oh my gosh of course you have all right whatever whatever
matias all right but that means it was one and a half a week ago so it means i forgot yeah your
context window is gone no that's great man so all right well then so you've actually done some more
hands-on stuff with it than i have because i've just done mostly reading and ideating on it um what
is your yeah share share a little bit about that would you i can share about that but i just it was
really interesting point that you brought up with this xlp because it is basically meant to like
transform the incoming xml document to something else yeah so
it's pre-parted you can transform it into something that now has an xsc in it that's yeah i guess that's
what you meant but it is have to revisit that because it's awesome that's great man i could see yeah he's
for those of you that are listening not watching on youtube there's like this far off look in his eyes
that is the the mark of of a bug forming i can see it that's great man i love that um yeah but
there's also a lot of stuff or there are some different a couple of different xsll libraries
but you can do like file system stuff yeah to and get like environment variables and stuff so
you can even do more stuff than with just normal yeah 100 and so yeah i'd like to normally before
people come on the podcast i message them and i say hey you know check out this document you know
that sort of thing right and then i also tell them hey bring a bug or two so that we can talk about it
on the pod and i totally forgot to do that for you for this episode so i'm sorry about that we can talk
about that one yeah can you can you give us some info on that that'd be great yeah so that one was you
could upload an xml okay through a bunch of different hoops you had to jump through but it ended
with like you could provide an xml and then in another place you could provide an xslt document and
the funny thing is the xslt document is also specified as xml right and that that one was vulnerable to xlc but
i didn't find it because i tried it in the original document that was not vulnerable so then i was
like okay xslt i'm gonna learn it xslt specific box and then like after i played with it and talked to
franz about it he's like but this is the xsc freaking franz dude set up franz like get out of here who
invited you to this anyway but in another way so one noble trick that i learned with that was that
i forget exactly what the operation was called but there's like a couple of ways you can read files
and you can read json files with one operation i could find right it later and we can we can link to
this documentation yeah that's super cool right or you sorry you can read xml documents but you can also
read raw files yeah but the problem is so this is connecting to the next part actually of this secret
document you could also in the parser you weren't allowed to read read the new bytes into the
the resulting document you're like oh damn can't read like prox self-environment yeah like separated
windows uh but what you could do is specify the encoding of the file so what you could do is you
could tell it treat it as uh like github 16 for example and then spit out like a bunch of chinese
characters and then you could like transform that back and i knew that it was a java application so i
could just use hack worker and then know that it's like java versus java so i actually expected like
the environment via like reading the file as you did 16 and then turn it back dude that is you've been
doing so much crazy char set stuff lately man that's that's really cool that you bypass that with that
though that's that's an amazing idea i like i like i suppose like confusion bugs yeah like it's a broad
area it is they are my one of my favorites and encoding is like i i'm still not entirely sure i there's a
blog post actually i i can link it too it's like really old like it doesn't tattern or something sure and
it's called something like everything you need to know about encodings and short sets as a developer
okay i need that okay so yeah yeah and it starts from the beginning like in the beginning there was
everything within that there was the asking and then like the high bytes was not used for anything
and then so people started implementing whatever they wanted over like 0x80 and uh that wasn't really
standardized but then ibm was like okay we follow take all of them and we give them each code page
so now when you see like a short set it's like cp1234 yeah that's that's the code page wow dude that's
that's cool man i would love to read that document i think that i think a lot of our listeners would
love to read that too so i'll um well i'll follow up with you after that and try to try to get that in
in the description yeah um like encoding box is really really really interesting yeah also things
like injecting like byte order mark to confuse injecting what okay byte order mark oh byte order
mark yeah so you can use it in like you get 16 for example or like is this the like encoding flip it
around thing like the left to right override yeah exactly it's like if it's little engine or big
engine so like should the top byte come first or second oh oh yeah yeah so you're talking about like
um like uh utf 16 le utf 16 b is that what you're talking about exactly yeah exactly so if you just say
utf 16 right then it's ambiguous right you can start the document or the string of strings yeah
with like this byte order mark it's like fb ff i think for one of them and then it's like aha you're
telling me to what coding is okay so hold on wait a second so you can actually put that in the data
yeah what yeah
order
dang dude i need a bigger notepad for this episode
um byte order mark and so you can put that in the data and it will define how the rest of that data
string is read maybe it should have to start with it but i wouldn't be surprised if some people or
some are interpreters of ourselves they have it in the middle holy crap that's amazing that is that is
super i'm just kind of yeah now now i've got the thing in my head you know i'm looking off into the
into the distance and and ideating on on what what could become of that that's that's really really
interesting dude i'm definitely going to have to look into that after this um yeah thanks so much
for sharing that i'm sure that'll result in a bunch of in a bunch of bugs um yeah there's also some
encodings that have special i don't think it's called by door remarks but it's like special special
sequence of characters that like transform it so like in the middle of the document you can have
by blah and blah and then it's tons it to like okay now it's this other way of interpreting it and
it ends with something else no way there is encodings which is like okay now it's standard sq everything's
fine it's like no now it is not now it's this other thing dude that is so interesting so if you
could get them to parse it with that char set then you could really use that to bypass some
security controls because you know whatever parser will be looking at it and being like okay you know
this is just meaningless text and then when the actual end you know program runs it it's something
completely different because it's it's actually parsing the char set differently yeah yeah exactly so if
they have like a screen contains for example then they could be treated different dude this has
got to be this was the topic too and that is what i saw like normalization they can like transform it
into yeah somewhat some of the charts this is this is very and you know of course my mind goes directly
to web servers and reverse proxies and wafts and this is actually pretty much exactly what sam erb and i
were talking about and i don't know if you saw it in the document but i i did a talk on this at defcon
um on how you can define host headers for some uh for some http servers and you can define them in
different encodings right so literally our exploit for this bug was host and this is a host header
host colon equals question mark iso 8859-1 question mark q and then a bunch of hex data and that actually
got converted into our exploit on on the the back end of that um server that we were talking to a
bypass to nginx uh configuration that had some limits on the host header characters being used and allowed
us to inject right into the nginx config file on the back end because of the way that we could smuggle
characters like a space and stuff like that into the host header um and so now i'm thinking like man
there's got to be even more possibilities of this sort of thing with stuff that can change mid
you know mid uh mid flow and change into something else because maybe the nginx proxy on the front end
reads decodes the character set but the one on the back end doesn't and it doesn't normalize it
and then it just treats it like normal text and then you can pop xss or you can you know bypass
any sort of filtering in place yeah but like you also need to you when you're talking about xss you
need either you need server-side normalization for it to transform because when you're sending like
you're using you that's 16 for example yeah what you're actually sending is just two bytes and if
you want like a less than characters those two bytes will be no byte and 3c so if it filters 3c in like an
8-bit ascii encoding it will go like okay is this a 3c is this a 3c no sure sure you say yes and so
you need to need normalization or you need some kind of encoding supported in the client that where
like 0 0 3c or 0 0 3f yeah less than i'm wondering if there's other there's got to be other encodings
besides you know utf 8 utf 16 that put those at different code points right in browsers no well you
know and i linked actually funny you mentioned that matias because i did my homework for this episode and
if you click the first the first link under the character sets heading in the secret document i have
a link directly to the chromium source code in all of the different um uh character encodings that we
you know that can be used in here and i see one of them you know is this iso 8859-1 that i'm familiar
more familiar with from the the defcon talk and so i'm wondering if there's different ways you know or do
any of these different encodings put a different put the you know less than sign or greater than sign
or whatever at a different code point so that if if it bypasses the front end and says okay you know
the front end says this is uh you know a question mark but the back end says okay i'm actually not
reading this as as you know windows dash one you know one two five two and actually i'm interpreting this
as utf-8 or interpreting this as ascii and then you know you get the output as an actual script tag
does that does that make sense or am i thinking about this incorrectly i mean it's a good idea but
the the iso 8859 yeah it's different is no it is ascii based no no i know i know it's not what we're it
doesn't meet the standards of what we're we're looking at yeah but this there is something like that
then yes unfortunately i don't think that there is um any no master key supported for sets for like
html and dangerous content-writing browser so the the overlap anymore they used to be they used to be
yeah especially in like internet core had some special cases and like all of them at some points
for the utf-7 so it's just like seven seven bit so ascii ascii would be so the base for all of these is
what you're saying so yeah the first 256 characters of every single one that 3c is always going to be
the the angle bracket for for xss yeah ascii is the all the characters you need in one situation for
the english language so it starts at 0x20 and stopped at at the seven like smaller c yeah at least that's
how i learned in my room all right and we are on to the bug stories section so in this clip from
episode 27 we're going to be talking about the asset note share file rce uh specifically there was an
authentication bypass relating to the padding in aes 256 so make sure to check this clip out yeah yeah i
mean it's always there always anytime you see a blog post from asset note it's always very high quality
and it goes into a ton of detail about like their thought methodology and the path that they took to
get there and they do a really good job of explaining sort of like the attacker mindset as they're coming
towards something that like from the title you can tell is very severe yeah you know it's an rce so i think
that provides sort of a unique insight and oftentimes it's not like this super straightforward type of like
like oh i put like id like semi colon id yeah in in a core parameter and it pops you know like it's
usually a little bit more in depth and it goes into like how they discovered it and yeah files that they
were looking for and the patterns and stuff and i think like that's really useful because a lot of
times you see sort of like the black box approach where it's like i was just fuzzing this endpoint i saw
an interesting parameter i tried a command injection and it worked and that's it and you don't really
get the understanding for like what that looks like on the on the back end or like the engineering side
or like if you were doing source code review how that might um how that might look and so i think
uh it's really awesome to see the blog posts that they put out because they go into that level of
detail sure as always i love the methodology and the write-up they they talk about they dump all the
files they they talk about um this this uh i guess function that's getting called to parse the cookie
set current principle from session cookie um which you know if you were just kind of looking through
the code you might assume that that is going to be something that does you know an authentication
check and in fact the title of that section they they titled authenticated but not really um because
that once you double click into that that you know that call it just skips over it if it doesn't
find the cookie that it was looking for um and so it's like okay well sort of that was going to be an
authentication check and there's some other pieces down the line where um you know you would assume
authentication was was um was necessary but they kind of you know weave around out of those and
eventually end up finding a path traversal not in um let me see if i can find the name of the parameter
it's not in the parameter that you would think um here it is right here yeah so it's it's not in the
parameter that allows you to specify the path it's a it's a in the upload id parameter um and that gets
concatenated with the path a little bit later and even though the path is actually um sanitized uh the
uh upload id is not which meaning which results in the path traversal which allowed them to get arbitrary
file right so that was a really i think that was a really good method and then this one also sort of has
a little bit of an a a twist to it which is you need to have a a valid parent id within the application
and so that parent id um you might assume would be something you might have to have like a valid folder
or valid um you know id of a folder or something but really they found that all you have to do is have
a um string that does not fail when it gets uh aes decrypted and so it doesn't matter what that string
is it's not used anywhere but if it if it is if it gets uh you know if it passes the aes decryption
then you're able to to do the attack so they they outline really well um how aes works how um the pkcs
7 padding works and how they were able to use that to um really reliably guess a value for this um parent id
i think it was only 128 or 256 um tries that it took to brute force and then they find a valid
value that will pop and result in them getting a shell so once again you know big round of applause
to the acid team awesome work they they killed it yeah yeah i think it's um it's really interesting
because this is a something that we talk about in app appsec a lot where it's like validation versus
verification and like total like a textbook example is jwt tokens where they're just checking is this a
valid jwt token not is the contents inside of the jwt token valid and so those are two very different
things like if you're just checking that this is a valid jwt token it can decode properly and that's it
and you're not actually checking who signed it or is the key correct and is the person who they're
saying they are in the jwt token actually who they are who they are like if you're not doing those
checks then that's where these little like weird weird edge cases because you might read through this
and i'm sure it's like whoever wrote this like didn't think that this was going to be an issue
they probably were like yeah just you know check if this is valid and go forward and that's not enough
you need to like also just verify like do that extra step and that that pitfall i think hits in a lot
of different areas uh yeah and you know this is just another example of you know in a big product
as well like just that classic kind of case where they checked it but they didn't fully verify yeah i
don't know about on the jwt front i kind of feel like that's the whole cell of the jwt though is that
like you know it should be sort of self-authenticating because it's signed by the you know by the person
that has the private key right so you know and obviously that doesn't always work out to be the case but
um you know these different technologies do have their different pitfalls and that is you know in
the jwt scenario as you mentioned that if somebody does you know find a way to forge a token or get
their hands on the private key or whatever then you're just totally screwed so yeah yeah so much
of that comes down to like which library you're using too like if you're just using a library that
separates out like validation and verification then that might just like put you in a big pitfall where
you're using the built-in library or something but it has an extra function that you needed to call
and you didn't know it or something like that and that oftentimes is just either a documentation
problem or something even stupider than that and you know it it happens to everybody so i think it's
just uh you know it's cool to see it in the wild and i think it's just something that you should always
keep keep an eye out for and just like you know check and see are they are they actually verifying my
my jwt contents can i just give it any sign jwt and will it work yeah so um i guess bringing it
back to the blog post i did have one more thing that i'll just try to explain from you know without
you having to go and read the blog post which is like i i've done a couple deep dives on aes
and um and you know the padding portion of it for padding oracle attacks so for those of you that have
done that in the past and want a little bit of a refresher the way that the uh pkcs 7 padding works is
that you've got your you know you've got your 16 uh byte blocks and then when you don't have when
your data does not sum up to 16 bytes the rest of that 16 bytes is filled by the value that is the
number of remaining bytes so if you've got 15 uh you know bytes in that in that block and you need to
get one more that last byte is going to contain the a byte that points to one and if it's you know 14
then it's going to have zero zero zero zero two right um and so that that's something that i had
back there you know in in the memory database and that but just doesn't come you know sometimes when
i need it to so there's your little refresher on on um aes uh padding protocol for any of you that are
interested in that that low level of cryptography yeah yeah yeah you probably see this a lot in ctf
like if you decrypt an aes block and it's not exactly the block length then it'll always have
like trailing bytes that usually are not printable because it's from like 0x01 to 0x0f and so oftentimes
you'll be like oh what is that oh right i need to unpad it and there's like a some copy paste function
that i always use off stack overflow to do that in python yeah yeah no python man this is just another
great example because the exploit here is written in python is like you really if you're gonna try to get
to this level of you know pro hacking you need to be pretty handy with python or you know some sort
of scripting language so that you can just write out these pocs pretty quickly all righty next up
is one of my favorite clips from all of our ctbb podcasting from this last year a clip in which i
get to talk to alex chapman himself about a bug that i duped him on an alex chapman bug one of the
finest accomplishments in my book bounty career this is the perforce rce um hope you guys enjoy
this one i most certainly did this this was a bug at a live hacking event um earlier this year and it
was a rce that and and this is the thing that makes me sad too is that um this is a blog post that alex
wrote up on a specific vulnerability in a specific protocol uh perforce and um and i you know using
using to be fair to myself using other resources and alex's blog um i found you know an rce on this
on this target the shared target that we had and um and then uh i submitted the report before alex did
so he duped he did and we split the bounty right because it's a live hacking event dupe but um uh you
know it was one it was a really um great example of the way that alex alex thinks and and and what
we were talking about earlier with blogging about things that you're passionate about um and a perfect
example of this client server trust um sort of situation that we have because that's where the
vuln was um but and alex i i don't recall whether i sent you this specific vulnerability before we started
uh recording the podcast do you want to talk to the technical details of this vuln uh did you do you
have the it fresh enough in your mind or do you want me to take a stab at it and you can kind of supplement
yeah i think i've um i've actually been looking at again recently for something else so it is
oh what okay all right it's yeah talk us through it man talk us through it this is an interesting one
but it's again so for those who don't know perforce is a uh version control system so similar to git
or um svn that's heavily used in the gaming industry because it's it works really well with
very large files um so if you have really large assets 3d models that sort of thing um
and it it's a very typical example of the the client trust that we mentioned before so
all the um perforce client really does is connect to the server and the server then says run this
command and then server server will say okay show me what files you've got check the hashes of the
files against the files i've got so rather than it being client controlled it's server control
um and that that was the first thing kind of got my interest i was like well how does it do
how does it give you new files that you don't have on your system and it turns out it just sends a
uh i think the command is literally send file yeah or um right file client dash right file is what i
have in my report right here which is just gold like i love that sounds interesting yeah um
so then seeing that like okay right how how are we going to go about about testing this so what do
you do break out python and then start trying to reverse engineer the protocol as it's going on the
wire and wire shark and building up byte by byte bit by bit uh to a point where pretty much had a fully
functioning um purple server written in python um to kind of handle the auth do all the rest of it to
get it to the point um where with just a login it would be able to write an arbitrary file on the
on the connecting system and and that was great so i think justin saying this this bug collection
collision on the uh life hacking event i i kind of have a bit of a blasé attitude to submitting these
bugs that i don't think anybody else is going to submit and this one i wasn't going to submit in
the do period i was like nobody's going to find that oh dude oh that would have been a nightmare man
i'll prove it after the dp closes uh because nobody else will find it and it's like oh i've got a little
bit of time i'll i'll get it here holy moly and then when i found out it'd been jake just like oh
yeah you start submitting everything
i still practice yeah right as soon as it was juped i went to the uh tradition i was like um
can you let me know who who who was it i want to have a word it was it was um and and it was i want
to say on your team as well they took you guys took bets on who it was right and and freak who who was
it they guessed it was me one of them correctly guessed that it was me was it yeah it might have been
douglas i want to say it was douglas as well yeah so i appreciated that vote of confidence it is a
uh one of the highest honors in my bug bounty career to have duped an alex jatman bug
um so i'm sorry for using your own blog post against you but um yeah i completely forgot i'd
written that to be honest so uh did you really no way so you didn't even reference back to it when you
when you had oh my gosh wow that's crazy um that's awesome and and so i just wanted to go to what
you were saying you know you wrote out a full a full perforce server and i'm looking at my exploit right
now and uh you know i i love that experience of writing out you know like a binary level protocol
um for these sort of things and you know you said that handles the auth and stuff like that i'm looking
at my code and it you know handles the auth it's just like yeah yeah don't mind that you know like
you know it connects to the server you're like no no it's fine yes yes you got it correct you know
and then and then you just yeah yes you're more connected here's the code run um and it's just uh
it's just a fun vulnerability type for sure all right and you've made it to the very last clip
probably if this is in order unlikely this is from unlikely maybe otherwise welcome to the
middle of the video or something this is from episode 48 uh an awesome episode with the mbh defcon
black badge earner googler sam herb sam is talking about an xslt bug that he found and it's just a
really awesome story so make sure to listen to this one so i mentioned um on the samuel podcast a while
back that uh sam was one of the first people that introduced me to xslt um and so sam i was wondering
if you could share a little bit about that bug and yeah just kind of talk to us about that yeah so this
was that this is like one of the first life hacking events i attended and uh there was this endpoint that
accepted um it was xml but it wasn't xml it's xslt which is like a data transformation language
and okay so it accepted uh xslt directly yes um but it oh it would accept like it was like you'd accept
like your your input and then the xslt to transform it with um and so it's one of those like uh business
logic type languages that like well i'm probably butchering this for xslt experts um but it's one of
those business logic type languages that allow you to transform data kind of arbitrarily in like
uh a user-friendly way like you know somebody who can write an excel document can go and write this
xml format um and so apparently after as i found out like actually a lot of folks sort of folks at
this live hacking event found this endpoint and just kind of did a simple like xsc payload and kind of
called it a day um yep i decided to spend a bunch of extra hours digging into this classic classic sam
what i actually ended up doing was like i actually went to the function reference and i stepped
through every function uh i'm sorry hold up what yeah so so you you did you take up like did you
somehow leak the library name and then set up your own local instance and then hook up a debugger i mean
whoa whoa whoa whoa what did we do there yes i think it was open source so i'm pretty sure i sent my own
instance of this uh just to test it out um but then like i just wanted i just want to highlight how
sam was like yeah so anyway i thought this was interesting so i just you know uh put a breakpoint
on the debugger i was like what yeah i mean to be fair like many hours in i have to try many different
things like there's there are a fair number of public xsl t exploits and like this seemed to be fairly
patched um so i did so yeah if i recall correctly i just said my own instance and this was like 2019
no this is even earlier this would have been 2018 or 2017. um and yeah i just stepped through every
function saw what it did and then i eventually realized that like you could string like two or
three of these functions together to get like a really cool um uh lfi gadget and i believe i also
had an rc gadget in there as well yes you did but i just remember that because like i was like
there were some limitations around it like it was there was a couple i don't recall exactly what
limitation was but like i kept trying to exploit it further and i couldn't like maybe i couldn't like
pivot to root or something like that and so i actually gave a presentation on live hacking event
afterwards like showing us off which is probably where you remember from yes and i was like oh yeah you
know i'm like really disappointed in this bug you know i thought i could take it further and i i think it
was uh doggy g was like dude like you still got a crit like yeah like chill it out like you're just
reading you know arbitrary files from production on a multi-billion dollar company like just just accept
it take the dub you know yeah dude uh xslt is a really interesting thing that i'm looking forward to
diving into a little bit more when i find um i think you know so like that's something that takes it i'm
sorry good no go go go i was gonna say um there's like this whole class of like business logic
languages and things that aren't really ever meant to be exposed to the internet and when they are
resulted in really scary things and it's like there's been efforts to lock these down but like
often they weren't really ever built to be locked down and so like this they're just gonna be they're
gonna continue to be kind of like a source of vulnerabilities going forward and you know i think that that's a
great area for more original research yeah i mean we even see this with with xml right like xml is a
data markup language like why does it have this functionality to like read local files and send http
requests right um so really it is cool anytime you see the opportunity to do something like like that where
you're actually parsing some type of code you know um on the server side big money there
already dude that's a wrap that was a long ass episode filled with some amazing content it was
kind of amazing i'm not gonna lie to go back and like review over this year and see all the amazing
things we've talked about it was it was a blast it's been such an awesome year so i hope that all this
all these little clips and tidbits and stuff you'll be just playing it over and over on loop i know i
will i have so many different notes and awesome learnings to take away from this yeah man i i
actually had another as we went back there and re-listened for the clips i have a full notebook
uh you know of stuff that i need to go back and re-research again so yeah it's been a great year
thanks everyone for listening and we're gonna bring some awesome content as well in 2024 so hope you keep
listening i almost forgot i also want to give a big shout out to those members of the critical
thinking discord community that helped with the selection of the clips for this awesome mega episode
that's tharnet set 47 xss doctor buck luck bebex ug leak and pj stew so thank you guys so much for
all of your help and for going over a lot of critical thinking content with me to find the best clips for
for this episode